the mouse wriggles desperately under the
cat's paw as the long curved feline
claws dig into its furry skin it squeaks
with the Primal Terror of a creature
that knows it's about to be devoured
alive no matter how hard it tries it
can't escape it's in the clutches of its
perfect Predator as the mouse fights for
its life the cat licks its fangs and
descends towards its frightened prey but
before it can sink its fangs into the
mouse's body the cat opens its mouth and
says sorry about this but I don't have a
choice in perfect English it started
with a man named Maurice whose
girlfriend was currently in the process
of dumping him the two of them sat in
the diner over cups of coffee and
mediocre eggs as she tried her best to
let him down gently but Maurice his eyes
glistening with tears didn't want to get
out that easy he asked his former
girlfriend Laura in case you were
interested
why she didn't want to be with him
anymore for reasons even she didn't
understand Laura decided that on that
fateful day she would be honest with the
man she was dumping she told him that he
is a nice guy he's just kind of boring
specifically he just isn't cultured he
only listens to Top 40 Music doesn't
watch any movies that don't have
superheroes in them she can't even
remember the most recent time she saw
him reading a book and never once in
their three-year relationship sh has she
ever seen him take an interest in art
Laura wishes Maurice a nice life and
leaves the diner the next couple of
weeks are hell for poor Maurice he
doesn't know what to do with himself in
the single life he goes to work but
that's about it the rest of the time he
cries he sleeps he eats whole buckets of
Ben & Jerry's and he rewatches the same
set of movies that Laura left him for
watching in the first place he's stuck
in a rut and endless loop and as he lays
on his couch in the dead of night while
Avengers Infinity War plays out on his
screen for the 21st time he notices how
blank his walls are bereft of even a
single poster photo or painting that's
when it hits him you call me uncultured
I'll show you Laura I can be plenty
cultured when I want to be that same
night he Googled art dealerships in his
area and found something interesting
Archibald's art and Antiquities on a
20-minute walk from his apartment the
place was apparently accredited with
sponsorships from something called MC
and d and also claiming to feature some
acclaimed pieces of Ann art from the
fine folks of the AWC Collective all of
this went over Maurice's not
particularly cultured head but he
decided he definitely be visiting the
place first thing in the morning when he
arrives after shaving and washing his
hair for the first time in over 2 weeks
he's feeling optim Mystic about his
prospects it is a classy looking store
the exact kind of thing he was expecting
when he read about the place online
there's even a handp painted open sign
in the front window the store owner
archbald presumably greets Maurice in
the doorway he's an old man with thick
black glasses and a white walking cane
is he blind Maurice is confused by that
a blind art dealer feels kind of like a
comedian who can't speak but the dealer
is polite and tells Maurice to look
around to his heart's content once again
Maurice feels a little out of his depth
on some level he knows Laura was right
he doesn't know the first thing about
art none of it was connecting his eyes
passed over paintings sculptures and
artistic photos with no effect he was
worried for a while that perhaps he was
truly hopeless until his eyes met with a
truly glorious sight a painting that
spoke to him on the very deepest levels
of his soul it doesn't even have a title
but the second he sees it he just knows
it has to be his it's a painting of a
fat cat lying against a pile of pillows
without a care in the world it's
everything that Maurice wants to be in
his life relaxed unbothered Carefree
happy before he even knows it he's
reaching for his wallet a short
transaction with archal later and
Maurice returned home with his new prize
possession a painting that represented a
turning point in his life in more ways
than he could have ever understood with
a hammer and some Nails he mounted the
precious painting up on his wall so that
he could look at it for inspiration
every single day it's the start of a new
chapter maybe everything would be better
now little did Maurice know the
transformation had already started 1
hour after initial viewing it's like a
switch in Maurice's brain had been
flipped he was suddenly pulled out of
his post breakup depressive slump
rejuvenated reborn with the painting up
on his wall he started to look at the
apartment differently this place was a
dump where was the life where was the
effort he needed to make the rest of the
apartment worth the Grandeur of the
painting he started cleaning up and
looking at articles on fun he carefully
rearranged the place until it looked
perfect like the kind of place a woman
would be proud to go back to speaking of
which he signed up for some old dating
profiles taking a nicer happier selfie
to to represent himself somehow with the
painting in his possession anything
seemed possible the possibilities were
endless for the first time in a long
time thoughts of Laura didn't even cross
his mind he's thinking about the future
rather than the past about all the
wonderful things that he can do and
experience now that he's single he's on
his way to being cultured one day after
initial viewing Maurice is picking up
some new tastes while spending hours
browsing ing online retailers like Etsy
and Redbubble he finds himself drawn to
furniture and ornaments around one
particular subject cats it doesn't even
really strike him as that strange at
first after all so many of the Articles
he read about interior decoration
advised having a cohesive theme for your
living space like a nice rug it just
really ties the room together he buys a
rug shaped like a cat he buys some cat
cushions and throw pillows a picture
frame with a cat on it cat charms cat
statues cat statuettes cat everything
the more he puts into his home the more
it feels like it's meant to be and
really why stop at just decoration he
starts buying t-shirts with cats on them
and sweaters with Kawaii cat faces
lovingly embroidered into the fabric he
even buys a woolly hat with cat ears on
top for when the winter months roll
around as the quantity of cat based
merchandise in his home begins to
outweigh everything else another thought
wanders into his mind there's not a no
pets clause in his lease agreement why
doesn't he just cut to the Chase and get
himself an actual pet cat with a sense
of joy and excitement he hasn't felt in
a long time he starts to Google local
rescues where he might be able to adopt
a new furry little friend one week after
initial viewing Maurice has already made
some of his dreams into a reality he's
got a Cat Felix who wanders around his
home he's thinking about getting another
as he pours some kibble into Felix's
bowl or maybe two others a whole family
of cuddly kitties to keep him company
why would he even need a girlfriend he
starts to think about how everyone would
be happier if they had a cat or two in
their life this is the thought that
inspires his new information campaign he
starts with the people at work telling
anyone who will listen to him about how
getting a cat has changed his life when
he does go on occasional dates his
favorite topic of conversation is of
course his feline friends he can't wait
to ask ask his potential Partners
whether they're cat people or dog people
and if they're undecided he eagerly
takes the opportunity to convert them it
didn't take long for his almost holy
mission to go further he wants to make
people's lives better and his life
started getting better when he first
bought that wonderful painting he tries
his best to convince people to come back
to his apartment just so they can take a
look at the painting most people
politely declin the offer 3 weeks after
initial viewing the changes to Maurice's
Behavior became a little more drastic
he's become so obsessed with the feline
lifestyle that his own behavior begins
to take on a kind of cat-like Dimension
he doesn't feel the need to take a
shower or bathe anymore why would he
need to when he can just lick himself
clean the same goes for eating why sit
at a table with a plate and a knife and
fork instead he eats directly off the
ground with his hands and mouth he
drinks milk out of a saucer hungrily
lapping it up some days he doesn't even
feel like walking bipedally he'll walk
on his hands and feet with his rear
sticking up in the air somehow it feels
more comfortable than walking normally
but the Transformations are only just
beginning 2 months after initial viewing
Maurice has started to notice that his
stubble is growing out faster than usual
sometimes he needs to shave twice a day
if he wants to stay neat but what began
with the stubble would soon grow quickly
out of proportion his eyebrows became
wild and bushy his hair started to
become almost a Mane growing out in
thick mutton chops and creeping down his
neck towards his back his arm and leg
hair the hair on his chest and his back
at a certain point shaving felt futile
he just let it grow out soon enough it
didn't look like hair it looked more
like well fur just like the soft silky
fur on his beloved Felix Maurice doesn't
mind it in fact he's starting to love it
with a cat in a room full of cat
memorabilia all overseen by his
beautiful perfect cat painting Maurice
fits right in here 4 months after
initial viewing Maurice woke up one
morning to find something strange about
himself even Stranger Than everything
else he's gotten smaller no it's not as
though he's lost weight he's physically
gotten smaller had Maurice been the kind
of guy who likes to habitually visit the
doctor they would have told him that his
skeletal structure had somehow
contracted along with his skin and
musculature nothing is out of proportion
it's almost like he's gradually been hit
with a kind of Science Fiction shrink
ray Maurice doesn't pay much mind to it
of course he only noticed that he gotten
shorter when he went to lovingly gaze at
his painting and noticed that he was
looking at it from a slightly different
angle than usual but that's fine much
like Maurice himself now it's snow
biggie if anything it's a real treat to
see his prized possession from a
slightly different perspective while
Maurice didn't know it at this point he
was only 2 months away from fully
completing the process he'd started
undergoing Just 4 months earlier 5
months after initial viewing the most
obvious of the changes started occurring
at this point for a few months now
people at the office had been politely
ignoring the peculiar changes to
Maurice's size and skin and his tendency
to treat lunch break very differently to
his colleagues but the alterations that
began at month 5 were impossible
possible to ignore first the ears they
disappeared against the sides of
Maurice's head instead two other ears
pointy and furry popped out of the top
of his skull half hidden amongst his
hair then came the eyes his sclera
disappeared and his pupils lengthened
and narrowed into black feline slits and
of course most inconvenient to Mar's
daily life the disappearances of his
thumbs and fingers they shortened down
to furry Nubs until his hands weren't
hands at all they were more like paw the
transformation is almost complete 6
months after initial viewing by now the
transformation is complete getting into
art has changed Maurice's life forever
he has now quite literally become a cat
he paused through his apartment with his
best friend Felix eating kibble to his
heart's content the one difference being
that Maurice despite his new form
retains all of his personality and mind
he can even talk if you're the kind of
person who enjoys talking to cats
because Maurice had the foresight to
leave a window open before the
transformation fully took hold he and
Felix could come and go as they pleased
when the kibble ran out they started
running through the alleys together
forging for scraps and hunting down mice
and birds for sustenance Maurice was
reported missing a month ago and there
have been no leads in the case posters
went up searches were performed but
nothing was ever never found a few
months after that he'd been declared
legally dead to the human world at least
Laura never thought about him again
after the news report stopped and
eventually his apartment was cleared out
and resold he and Felix would spend the
rest of their days eaing out a strange
little existence together on the streets
just taking it day by day and despite it
all Maurice is happy in case you somehow
hadn't gathered from all that SCP 3270
is an anomalous painting of a cat
lounging against a pillow isn't he
adorable you may be inclined to agree
but if you encounter the painting in
person that agreement may come at a
heavy cost while seeing secondary
reproductions of the painting has no
anomalous effect seeing the real thing
in person will cause horrific changes to
the human body little by little anyone
who observes the painting directly has a
considerable chance of turning into a
cat designated SCP
these are no ordinary cats of course
they're cats with human intelligence
human lifespans and even the ability to
speak despite CAD physiology not being
compatible with human speech the
painting itself is kept in site 64 and
any humans turned into cats by its
anomalous powers are kept in site 888
where they're very well taken care of
the idea of being turned into a cat and
forever forsaking your Humanity might
horrify you but you shouldn't worry
about it too much after all cats have it
pretty well you've just had a night of
your life in beautiful Las Vegas Nevada
you spent hours shooting craps dancing
in clubs and eating more than your fill
at the famous all you can eat buffets
you're staggering back to your hotel
room high on life in the early hours of
the morning when you notice something
strange a long dark tunnel just off the
side of the strip you didn't notice it
on the way in perhaps because you were
distracted by all the glitz glamour and
hypnotic Casino lights you see the
tunnel and your overstimulated mind
feels drawn to it you stumble in and
start walking during your walk you can
feel your bones cracking they don't
shatter like you've just been hit by a
train they shift you feel the entire
shape of you bending into something
different but it doesn't stop with your
skeleton your organs start to feel
strange and then your skin in the
complete darkness of the tunnel you have
no idea what's going on so you just keep
walking eventually you find your way
into a lush green forest it's beautiful
but it feels like it should be a million
miles away from the Arid desert of
Nevada you were only in the tunnel for a
few minutes what gives hello you call
out is anybody there no answer you
explore further into this empty Forest
it's trees are far as the eye can see
but no animals that's when you see
something that catches your eye a puddle
of crystal clear water but it's not the
puddle itself that draws your attention
it's what reflects back at you when you
stare into it at first you can hardly
believe it but as you move your mouth in
shock and the reflection moves its mouth
too it's suddenly all too real you've
been turned into a fox an orange bushy
tailed fox you scream and bolt all the
way back to the tunnel that led you here
you sprint through and feel your entire
body changing once more when you finally
hit the wall of dry Vegas heat on the
other side you're human again you
breathe a sigh of relief and stumble
back to your hotel room the next day you
only vaguely remember what happened and
because you're not crazy you assume it
was just all a wild dream what you just
encountered is a uclid class SCP known
as SCP
2746 a seemingly innocent tunnel near
the Vegas Strip which holds a portal to
a Fantastical World designated by the
foundation as SCP
27461 by the time the foundation
discovered and secured the SCP 2746
tunnel and began sending their field
agents and researchers on fact finding
Expeditions inside the place was already
a ghost town a forested land mass
approximately 111 km in diameter with no
notable Signs of Life the foundation
discovered that this place had a strange
effect on people and animals who came in
from our world humans who entered
assumed the form of a random animal but
retained their intelligence and vocal
cords creating talking animals animals
brought into
27461 retained their animalistic
intelligence but grew humanlike vocal
cords allowing them to repeat simple
phrases before the mass Exodus or
Extinction event that left
27461 Baron the foundation figured out
that this place was populated by a whole
civilization of intelligent animals
like something out of a fairy tale these
animals through a mix of brains and
Magic were able to leave written records
and create impressive architecture like
homes and places of worship Foundation
researchers became fascinated with how
exactly this Society operated and what
could have led to its sudden downfall
thanks to a mix of advanced archaeology
and Records left behind by the creatures
this is what the foundation determined
the society these talking intelligent
animals lived in was a kind of religious
oligarchy meaning power was Consolidated
by the few in the top social class
Society was divided into three segments
Crafters Scholars and honorables with
the Crafters being the most powerful
members of society and honorables being
the least powerful the state sponsored
church is acted in worship of a being
simply called the maker who fills a
similar role to the abrahamic god the
Crafters whose number total 13 were
believed to be immortal and were were
responsible for building the majority of
the culture and architecture found in
27461 the scholars acted as their wise
assistance and the honorables were a
mixed class of artists carpenters and
Artisans it seemed that this culture had
a pretty good thing going no system of
currency was ever invented and the
economy operated on a barter system the
foundation believes that initially the
citizens of this world didn't need to
eat to survive and so only needed to
barter for material Goods though it's
worth noting that the conditions of
immortality only apply to natives of
this region people born on Earth but
assuming animal forms while entering
27461 still need nutrition to survive
however a great tragedy soon caused a
fundamental shift in the balance of life
and Society within
27461 the maker decided it wanted to
test or punish its subjects with two
major changes first humans would be
forbidden from entering the domain and
second the maker now made the
consumption of food necessary for
continued survival and Sanity nothing
was ever the same because nobody had
needed to eat prior to this food stores
had never been made and the inhabitants
had no agricultural knowledge that would
allow them to easily mass-produce more
as a result while the crafters and
Scholars were able to feed on fruits
from luxurious private Gardens the
honorables were forced to resort to
eating each other or other inhabitants
of
27461 this began a bloody Rift that
split Society from the top down one half
led by the powerful Crafters sari and
suard wanted to preserve society as it
was and continue to worship the maker
sari took the form of a Flemish giant
rabbit and Seward appeared as a houseat
the opposition led by former Crafters
Frederick and agathos with The Reluctant
help of a scholar named Clovis wanted to
get revenge on the maker for all he'
done and kill him completely altering
Society don't be fooled by their
appearances though many of the
inhabitants of
27461 were fiercely intelligent
Sorcerers and the apocalyptic Civil War
they sparked came to be known to the
foundation as event Nash like many wars
there would be no real winners here only
survivors and even then not for long it
was a bloody and horrific War all
attempts at finding a diplomatic
solution failed Frederick and agathos
would not stop until they had the
maker's blood on their paws in the end
though they were defeated and for their
traitorous crimes they were to be
punished by SAR and Seward in horrific
ways to make examples of them since
neither could die they were given Fates
worse than death instead Frederick was
up first before the war he'd been a
leader prize for his courage and
Ingenuity he' created something known as
as the great fire which provided the
kingdom with light for his so-called
atrocities against the maker he was
given the punishment of permanent
crucifixion and relocation to a place
known as the under plane his snout was
cut off his face and he was set
permanently Ablaze in a manner that
would leave him forever suffering and
would make him appear to look like a
monster to all next went agathos she was
Frederick's sister and was seen as The
Mastermind of many of their schemes
she would be forever encased in white
clay and bled through her eyes until the
sing drains from her she's now a living
crying statue existing in a state of
permanent imprisonment for her part in
the crimes against the maker Clovis
because her involvement in the coupe was
unwilling was given a more minor
punishment one of her eyes was removed
and she was permanently placed in a
broken human body effectively banishing
her from her home in
27461 forever though they may have won
things didn't end much better for SAR
and sirra the Civil War had fractured
their world and in the aftermath the
survivors chose to leave in hopes of
finding a better life elsewhere sari and
Siro though felt partially responsible
for everything that had happened and so
they decided to remain in their Dying
World before they themselves died or
perhaps moved on to different forms
leaving their animal bodies behind they
left a final note
it was from this note that the
foundation learned much of the story of
SCP
2746 this may seem like a pretty open
and shut case another magical realm
destroyed by tragedy and Civil War much
like the land of fantasy and SCP
1762 but what's really bizarre here is
that this is only the tip of the iceberg
when it comes to the stories of some of
these key figures in the event nahash
first what became of the two Rebels
agathos and Frederick today they're two
parts of the feared and deadly SCP 1913
Frederick now going by Freddy is a
nightmarish faceless fire demon in the
form of a dog slavishly devoted to the
protection of his sister agathos now
known as Agatha still trapped in white
clay her leaking blood now deadly to the
touch Clovis is still believed to be in
League with agathos and Frederick and
may now be related to the Sinister SCP
1903 three a oneeyed rabbit-like human
but strangest of all is the possible
truth behind SAR and seor the two
devotees to the maker who remained in
27461 until their very last breath in
all likelihood these two were once
agents of the SCP foundation's Infamous
Las Vegas Branch they took on these more
animalistic forms after their deaths
sari may have once been agent Sarah
Crowley a Japanese American woman who
died in the line of duty in 1960 Seward
was once Dr Stuart Hayward ky's partner
his new name acting as a kind of fusion
of the first and last name he had in
life this is only the beginning of the
animal themed weirdness occurring around
site 45 the foundation's Vegas Branch
but this series of anomalies collected
under the term pitch Haven will have to
wait for another video after all you
know what they say what happens in Vegas
stays in Vegas roll up roll up Step
Right This Way ladies and gentlemen on
the other side of these canvas doors
you're about to witness something so
monstrous so hideous so repulsive that
it will turn your stomachs and fill you
with amazement the creature you'll find
in this tent has been known to elicit
all manner of responses from well-to-do
folks like yourselves you may want to
laugh at it you may want to strike it
down you may even want to throw rotten
fruit at it and believe you me we are
prepared for that you will find all
manner of Rotten Tomatoes eggs and other
festering foods that are begging to be
pelted for the low low price of 5 cents
per handful if you follow me through
these doors and gather around this cage
quietly perhaps you will see it wait for
your eyes to adjust to the dark and hold
your revulsion until you cannot bear it
anymore only then will we get to look at
the papery gray skin sagging loose over
a swollen gut Marvel at its Tre trunk
legs ly strong enough to support its own
weight its deformed trunk that hangs
limp off the front of its face and its
ridiculous ears that flap nervously when
it's afraid don't be afraid of the Tusk
sticking out from its face or its cries
of pain and anguish instead hold your
tongues and wait for if you're patient
enough and perhaps with a slight beating
it may even play us a song with the
valves on its trunk then and only then
you're permitted to pel the Elephant Man
with whatever you see fid as you bask in
the glory of Herman Fuller's circus of
the disquieting Reese Freeman didn't
have much of a choice but to joined the
circus at the age of 14 the cast out son
of a freed slave in New Orleans he spent
much of his early life wandering the
streets trying not to get into any
trouble in the late 1800s very few
places were interested in hiring a young
black man unless of course they were
looking to turn him back to the life
that his father had fought so hard to
escape that's why when was out fishing
one afternoon and saw a big red tent
going up on the outskirts of town he
couldn't help but Wander Over much to
his surprise a group of black men were
the ones raising the Marquee they didn't
look like slaves either Reese had never
heard of a circus the closest he'd ever
come to seeing was a traveling
entertainment cart that would sometimes
pop up around town with a dancing bear
in a cage or a glass ball in a pack of
tarot cards the brightly colored tents
that went up one after another were
enough to draw a crowd even the most
well-respected in New Orleans came out
for a look standing ankle deep in the
river Reese peered over at the man who
came out to address the throng dressed
in a long tail coat with a tall Top Hat
the man stood on a box of fruit and
waved a cane dramatically in the air
good folks of New Orleans what you're
about to witness tonight has never
before been seen this side of the
Mississippi wonders and amazement Galore
spectacle and intrig mystery and ahem
and just a touch of the impossible I go
by the name of Herman Fuller the most
talented and notorious circus master in
the entire United States the dazzling
array of shows that I've brought before
you is not for the faint of heart or the
weak of constitution your stomachs will
be turned and your minds may be altered
but it promises to be a knight that you
will never forget reys wasn't much
interested in any of what he had just
said this kind of two penni show was
reserved for the folks who had the money
to throw around on needless things like
smiling and having a nice evening what
Reese was far more interested in were
the groups of men working behind the
scenes pulling various carts and setting
up all of the Stalls a lot of them
didn't look much older than him a grin
spread across his face SCP 4409 insisted
on being interviewed in the dark with
all the lights in the interview chamber
Switched Off Dr Simon Crossley entered
the room room and sat down across from
the Elephant Man even in the dim light
though he was able to still make out
part of the man's features the ivory
tusks the hanging nose and the nervously
twitching ears the man had been picked
up in St Louis where local police had
found him panhandling in the streets
while he certainly seemed harmless
enough it was important for the
foundation to take him in just to be
sure sitting in the dark interview room
reys Freeman was apprehensive at first
about telling his son of the story a
life of being mocked spat on and chased
out of towns had left him with a real
distrust of other people that was
probably made worse by his apprehension
at being put in another cage within the
foundation he told Dr Crossley that he
was born as normal as could be that his
current ghastly Affliction was something
done to him quite some time ago but as
much as it pained him to recollect it
was a tale that he knew he'd probably
have to tell Dr Crossley replied that he
was all ears it took Dr Crossley a few
seconds to realize his faux paw SCP 4409
glared at him before continuing to
explain how he was made the way he was
ree Freeman had managed to land a job
with the circus surprisingly easily
despite having no previous experience
and no references to back him up Herman
Fuller took a shine to him it was menial
work and not many folks were up to doing
it but since ree had never had a job
before he didn't know any better he
started out at the bottom of the ladder
scraping out feces washing down old
cages and carrying heavy crates the one
scrawny 14-year-old boy quickly turned
into a stocky 17-year-old with broad
shoulders and strong legs they would
travel from town to town across most of
the United States stopping off in major
cities for weeks at a time to bring in
as much money as possible before moving
on Reese didn't save much of that money
but he didn't mind the fact that he got
two meals a day and something to do with
himself was enough in fact in fact he
kind of enjoyed sleeping on top of the
carts as the horses pulled them across
the dusty American roads the one thing
that always seemed to affect him though
was that he was never allowed to
actually see inside the tents he would
see folks come and go through the canvas
doors week after week but was never
allowed so much as a peak inside himself
the older guys were responsible for
throwing the canvas sheets over the
cages which would remain that way as
they traveled not having seen much of
the world at that point Reese didn't
have much much of an idea of what could
be in those cages perhaps some kind of
animal from a foreign country something
from Africa or Asia they made all kinds
of noise Reese said that most of them
sounded like humans but then they'd go
and make strange animal sounds that no
human mouth could ever produce one night
his curiosity got the better of him
hanging back before the crowds got into
the tent he Sid stepped over to the
entrance making sure that no one saw him
and took a peek through the doorway if
was dark inside too dark to make out
much of what was happening the crowd of
people was standing between him and the
cage all jostling and leaning this way
and that trying to make out whatever it
was that was inside a screeching sound
filled the air making the whole crowd
and Reese outside jump right standing on
his tiptoes he tried his best to see
what was moving around in that cage it
seemed to be moving around like a person
lurching this way and that but the
sounds coming from it sounded more like
a bird heard and sure enough after a
moment a huge pair of disproportionately
ugly Wings stretched out from either
side of the creature flapping and
sending a rush of air through the tent
so powerful that it blew the flap wide
open in front of him just as Herman
Fuller turned around to see him standing
there ree bolted and hid behind one of
the carts he was going to be in trouble
for this he was sure of it it was one of
Fuller's only rules of the circus and he
had just gone and broken it he was in
the hottest water imaginable but as
nighttime fell and the drags of the
spectators wandered out of the tent
Fuller seemed to be in too bad a mood at
all watching him from a distance reys
got the impression that he might not
actually be in as much trouble as he
thought Fuller caught his eye and came
over cane twirling and Top Hat sitting
jauntily at top his head Rees got off on
the wrong foot apologizing right away
for spying into the tent the circus
Master just laughed it off and slapped
him on the back R my boy Bo don't worry
about it I've got much bigger plans for
you much much bigger that night as Reese
lay in bed he had a terrible dream about
what he had seen in the tent that day
circus of the disquieting was certainly
an apt title for this place the image of
that strange shadowy bird person in the
cage haunted his nightmares until
suddenly two pairs of strong hands
gripped him and ripped him out of his
sleep he knew better than to fight back
this was surely going to be his
comeuppence for breaking Fuller's rules
earlier they dragged him into the main
tent where there was an oil lamp in the
middle Illuminating what looked like a
heavy wooden operating table his wrists
and ankles were strapped in and then the
two men left him alone he had half a
mind to scream but with all the Caged up
creatures from the circus around him he
doubted anyone would pay him much mind
it was almost an hour before Herman
Fuller walked into the tent by this
point reys expected him to be walking in
with surgical equipment gloves maybe
even a saw but the man had nothing in
his bare hands Herman Fuller asked him
if he ever heard of Joseph Merrick Reese
didn't answer of course he had heard of
the Elephant Man the whole world had
been talking about Joseph Merrick for
months a man born so hideously deformed
that people had compared him to an
elephant though the resemblance wasn't
that convincing this sentiment was
clearly shared by Fuller who placed one
hand on either side of Reese's face and
began to Softly massage his cheeks
explaining how disappointed he was that
Merck didn't actually look all that much
like an elephant ree's cheeks started to
hurt as the man massaged him almost as
if he was stretching and pulling at his
face finding loose skin the boy asked
Fuller what he was doing the circus
Master just smiled at him and explained
that it was an old technique handed down
in his family a gift he called it he
started touching Reese's nose gently
pulling at it with more and more
pressure much to Reese's surprise he
felt his nose elongating growing longer
and longer in the man's hand he tried to
Twitch his face and was starting to find
that his new nose twitched along with it
the longer it grew the more painful it
felt the skin and flesh from his head
being ripped and pulled into a new shape
at several points Reese felt ready to
pass out from the agony but the circus
Master kept talking to him kept him
awake through the whole ordeal as he
molded the boy's face like clay into the
shape of an elephant lying on the bench
panting reys could see his trunk from
between his two eyes it was a nightmare
that was all it was but then Fuller
reached under the workbench and lifted
out a small hand drill one by one he
punched holes into the top of Reese's
trunk installing little valves like a
trumpet as he went standing back to
admire his handiwork he told Reese that
he would be his new favorite attraction
my boy I have made you into a star the
tusks did not come straight away over
the course of several months they slowly
and painfully emerged from his deformed
jaw his elephantine legs were also not
part of his initial transformation but
instead came as a result of health
issues he developed while being trapped
in a cage for several decades crowds of
people would come and go flocking to see
the Elephant Man having spent the first
part of his life constantly hungry Reed
was now being overfed every day hands
would come to his cage and force him to
eat Rich fatty foods denying him any
possibility of exercise the broad
shoulders and strong legs that he had
developed while working at the circus
melted away under layers and layers of
fat his skin went gray and papery
folding and wrinkling in on itself
either from Fuller's magic or just from
a lack of sunlight whatever it was with
every passing day Reese Freeman steadily
became more more and more hideous SCP
4409 was stuck in the circus for much of
his life eventually Herman Fuller moved
on and is currently being hunted by the
SCP Foundation when he did SCP 4409 was
able to bargain for its freedom from the
circus wandering from City to City never
sticking around for very long SCP 4409
begged for change at the side of the
road some people would feel sympathy
While most would feel horror at its
disfigurement from its years trapped in
a cage SCP 4409 has developed severe
health issues including gout severe
obesity and metabolic syndrome while in
Foundation custody it is fed a special
diet to counteract these conditions as
of yet the foundation has no way of
reversing what was done to Reese Freeman
in the tent in the 1800s as Reese poses
no threat to the foundation he is
allowed to live with relative Freedom or
at least as much Freedom as a contained
SCP can earn his health condition
severely limits his m M ility around
site 66 a low security residential
containment area unable to walk even
moderate distances SCP 4409 heavily
relies on the use of a cane and a
heavyduty walker capable of supporting
up to 140 kg researchers listen intently
at his door waiting to hear if he's ever
going to play a sad song on his trumpet
but no sound ever emerges except for his
heavy breathing and spluttering coughs
it appears that having spent decades
lock in a small cage a sedentary life is
all he knows now with every opportunity
to exercise read books and take up new
hobbies SCP 4409 appears unable to
engage with anything other than sitting
and staring at the same spot on the wall
every day if an animal has spent its
whole life living in a zoo and finds in
its old age that one of the walls has
fallen down what use has it in taking a
step outside it has been often said that
dog is man's best friend and obviously
that isn't just exclusive to men ask any
pet owner whether they own a dog cat
rabbit hamster or soul sucking
interdimensional parasitic monster with
too many tentacles and they'll all tell
you the same your pet can be your best
friend they can give you the most
unconditional affectionate form of love
possible and as long as you treat your
little buddy right they'll be loyal to
you for the rest of your life and theirs
it's not uncommon for a pet to outlive
their owner especially if they belong to
someone who's elderly and that might be
a sad thing to think about for some
although it is important to remember the
positives like how much happiness and
companionship that animal would have
brought an aging owner in their last
years of life even someone younger who
dies unexpectedly might have had their
quality of life infinitely improved by
owning a loving pet to make them smile
but on the other hand there's the
negative downside that now some pets
have to live on after a tragic death not
fully understanding where their beloved
owner went so often we hear stories of
dogs that waited for their Master to
come home only for them to never walk
through the front door again and it's
equally hard when things pan out the
opposite way and an owner loses their
pet the one silver lining is that we as
human beings have a far greater
understanding of death and the grief it
causes we know that eventually despite
how hard it can be to adjust to that
initial heartbreaking loss it is
possible to move on and for things to
one day get better but what happens when
someone can't accept the death of their
beloved animal companion when the
unconditional love of their pet is
suddenly missing from their life how far
will a person go to recapture that
feeling how long does it take for grief
born out of love to become an unhealthy
fixation and what is the true price of
obsession well the answer involves SCP 5
89 both what it can give and just as
easily take away for as long as she
could remember and even further back
than that Aaron and her dog Poncho had
been Inseparable ever since her mom had
first adopted that scrappy little Jack
Russell Terrier Aaron had fallen head
over heels in love with that little
rascal loving a pet is different from
loving another person because they just
can't help showing how much they love
you back humans for all their good
qualities are so nuanced and not
everyone is honest with each other all
of the time but a pet especially a dog
even though they can't speak a bark or a
whimper or excited wagging of a tail can
easily tell you how they're feeling and
Poncho was no exception Aaron and her
mom Cleo lived alone it was just the two
of them for quite a long time and while
Cleo had little problem with that she
couldn't help but notice how isolating
it was for her daughter from a young age
Aaron had always been been quiet kept to
herself at school her mom kept expecting
her to make some friends asked to invite
them over or vice versa but it didn't
seem to be happening it didn't seem to
be bothering her daughter but Cleo was
worried that it was giving her the wrong
idea that being on her own was somehow
better so in an effort to give Aaron at
least one source of companionship Poncho
joined the family brown patches dotted
over his white fur he was the perfect
pet an excitable and loving little puppy
that Aaron was immediately smitten with
when Cleo told her he was hers to keep
being only 7 years old Aaron broke down
crying with tears of joy her mom had let
her pick out a name for him and she'd
quickly settled on Poncho at first Aaron
had meant to say it differently in order
to name the pup after a friendly
character from her favorite animated
movie but had mispronounced it in her
excitement at meeting the energetic dog
for the first time the name quickly
stuck though and as as the years went on
and Poncho got bigger Aaron bought her
four-legged best friend a little Poncho
of his own to wear when it started
raining over the following years Poncho
became Aaron's most constant and loving
companion even as she grew up moving
through her childhood and found making
friends a little easier with every
passing year there never came a time
when she didn't need her best friend
when Aaron had her first breakup in high
school and came home with floods of
Tears In Her Eyes Poncho could sense she
was upset and came wandering up to her
sitting in her lap to make her feel just
a little bit better then a few years
later when her mom got sick Aaron had to
take care of her a task that would have
been much harder without Poncho there to
alleviate that stress and lift her and
Cleo's spirits and when Cleo eventually
passed the little white and brown dog
sat quietly with his owner as she said
goodbye to her mom now that it was just
the two of them Aaron and Poncho were
living in a tiny apartment it was
cramped for one person person and a dog
but Aaron was just grateful to have a
place to live in the company of her
favorite pup besides Poncho wasn't a
puppy anymore in fact he hadn't raced
around the park or chased a ball for
quite a long time with the numerous
stresses of her everyday life least of
all holding down two jobs in her
desperate attempts to make enough money
to pay rent Aaron had hardly noticed the
signs Poncho was showing his age it had
been happening gradually in the
background over the years he wouldn't
chase the ball or Rel move around much
and when he did it was little more than
a lethargic plot around the apartment
perhaps it was because of such a
measured slower Pace change that Aaron
was unable to acknowledge it she could
see her old friend was getting more
tired sleeping longer his tail rely
wagging as much as it used to but by now
that felt like Poncho's normal behavior
then again given how important her dog
was to her it's just as likely she
didn't want to accept the truth that
unfortunately nothing lasts forever he
was almost 15 in human years which by
all accounts is an impressive age for a
dog especially one of Poncho's size and
breed it was on a day that Aaron was
outworking her morning job when it
happened the faithful adoring Jack
Russell Terrier who had spent his years
being nothing but loved and giving back
only more love in return curled up on
Aaron's bed the apartment was still
Silent not a sound to be heard save for
those last tired few breaths breaths
laying there maybe the dog wondered if
he'd ever get to see his friend again if
she would make it back from work in time
he closed his little brown eyes and
peacefully drifted off for one last
sleep during the break between her
shifts after the end of the one at her
first job and before starting her second
Aaron had just enough time to get home
usually she had just had enough time to
eat and get herself ready for the change
over then quickly check on Poncho before
having to dash back out poking her head
into the bedroom she saw her dog laying
right there on her bed there was a
Stillness to him that instantly made her
stomach drop his ears didn't move when
she called his name he didn't react when
she stroked his fur he was gone and the
moment she realized it Aaron felt like
her whole world had come crashing down
the loss of her oldest and closest
friend hurt almost as much as losing her
mom Aaron always felt that the problem
with funerals wasn't just how sad they
were or how it always seemed to rain
when she went to one instead it was more
that they could never properly sum up
just how much someone truly meant nobody
could ever condense the years worth of
love and memories into a burial and it
was worse when losing a pet there was no
procession no wake nobody else there
just her and Poncho saying goodbye a
final time eventually things got to be
too much the Heartbreak of Poncho's
death was another struggle in a lifetime
of lows that had all left their lasting
wounds on Aaron that coupled with the
stress of trying to carry on with a busy
life barely able to keep herself afloat
in either of her jobs had pushed her to
the edge of a breakdown maybe that's
what summoned it perhaps something had
sensed all of Aaron's mental anguish and
had come to seek her out it might have
been that her wishes for something some
little alleviation to all the pain and
stress were finally being granted or
maybe it was just a gift left by her
neighbor the sun had long since set when
Aaron arrived back at her apartment
stepping over the envelopes that
littered her doormat a few with words
like overdue and Urgent notice printed
on them in red ink passing through the
hallway Aaron paused as she always did
hoping to hear the gentle pattering of
Paws against the floor her therapist had
to suaded her from doing that saying it
would only make moving on from losing
Poncho worse she didn't care she wanted
her dog back and opening the door to her
bedroom it seemed like someone had been
listening sat on her bed with was a
stuffed animal right in the spot where
she'd found her little friend on that
horrible day it had been made to look
like a dog specifically resembling a
Jack Russell Terrier with brown patches
over its white fur the plushy was even
wearing a little rain poncho the side of
it was enough to cause Aaron to break
down in tears weeping in heavy sobbs as
she dashed across the bedroom to hold it
in her arms hugging it tightly her tears
seeped into the soft fur as she felt it
against her face she didn't even think
to question question where it had even
come from all she wanted to do in that
moment was hold the stuffed animal close
for the first time in what felt like
years a feeling of relief washed over
Aaron it was as if everything was
melting away the stress of work and the
toll of her tiring shifts gone all the
pain from losing Cleo and Poncho
dissipated too in fact it felt like she
now had her beloved dog back no it was
better than that it was almost as though
everything about pon Ono his energy his
Spirit the way he made her feel so calm
and loved was all distilled into this
stuffed animal and now it would never
grow old never age and die causing her
more pain Aaron gripped the soft toy
tightly the longer she held the hug for
the more her stress and sadness faded
her face was still wet with tears
although her sobbing had gradually
become low gentle Chuckles soon giving
way to a peel of uncontrollable laughter
rising in volume it was as though she
had taken something and the Very
chemistry of her brain was being altered
but after so much hardship it felt good
to the point where she was almost
lightheaded laying down on the floor of
her bedroom arms locked around the
plushy that reminded her so much of
Poncho Aaron continued softly giggling
to herself her entire body relaxed so
much so that every part of her felt like
warm butter as if she was about to start
melting through the floorboards although
she didn't know it or probably wouldn't
have even cared her dopamine levels were
spiking flooding her with the bodily
hormone that relieves stress and makes a
person feel good in fact right now she
was feeling better than she ever had
every day that followed Aaron would come
home to her stuffed animal her Poncho 2
as she liked to think of it it didn't
bother her how childlike anyone else
might find it for a grown woman to Ries
so heavily on a plushy for Comfort at
any rate it wasn't something she was
advertising to anyone else after after
every shift at both of her jobs she'd
race back to her apartment right to
Poncho 2 and just sit there just basking
in the way it made her feel it was the
most all-encompassing sense of euphoria
and relief reducing her stress so much
that she felt like she was floating her
body lighter than air that feeling was
all that mattered to her some days she
wouldn't even eat Poncho to was more
important to her than food gradually she
started to become addicted to that
feeling having to wait until the end of
her work shifts to feel that Rush of
happy chemicals flood her brain was too
long of a delay she started to Crave it
while working unable to focus feeling
erratic and Restless without Poncho too
of course she couldn't risk bringing it
to work with her what if someone took it
or she dropped it her boss might see her
with a stuffed animal at her desk and
fire her on the spot or think that she
was absolutely crazy the only safe place
for her source of relief was at home but
Ain knew she needed something to bridge
the gap while she was working the only
substitute that worked was taking a
photo of Poncho 2 on her phone then
blowing it up and printing off a copy
Aaron could carry it around portably
keeping it in her pocket and taking it
out to look at it every few minutes
while she worked the hid of positive
chemicals it gave her wasn't quite as
strong as getting to hold her stuffed
animal after all it was just a grainy
photo from her phone essentially acting
like a patch to tide her over until she
could get back home to the real thing
however it didn't take long for Aaron to
start taking Poncho with her anywhere
that wasn't work to the grocery store to
visit her mom and her dog and of course
to therapy I'm rather concerned about
this pattern of behavior Aon
psychotherapist Dr Lee stated when her
patient explained what had been
happening sitting across on the opposite
side of her office on a leather couch
Aaron had Poncho 2 pressed tightly
against her I don't care she sighed her
brain already a wash with hormones that
kept her C M I like how it makes me feel
so I don't care Aon look at yourself Dr
Lee urged you aren't properly dealing
with your grief it seems to me you're
channeling all your desire for positive
emotion into this stuffed animal Poncho
to Aaron corrected her without taking
her eyes off the soft brown and white
dog and its little cloak listen to me
the therapist insisted trying
desperately to get through to her Poncho
your dog your real dog is gone you lost
him 6 months months ago and your mom
Cleo she passed away too you have to
process and come to terms with those
things as sad as they might make you
feel that's how we move on but what
you're doing right now isn't healthy
Aaron it's becoming an obsession Turning
Away Aaron pressed Poncho 2 up against
her face I don't care she repeated by
now Aaron had become fully dependent on
Poncho 2 showing up late for both jobs
just so she could spend longer feeling
those endorphins and hormones that
hugging the stuffed animal seemed to
bring it didn't take long for her to
start skipping entire shifts for days at
a time and canceling any and all other
plans just to sit at home basking in the
relief brought on by her apparent
Obsession her apartment became a mess
untied piles of mail by the front door
the walls plastered with hundreds of
photos of her stuffed animal fueling her
Obsession her evening job was the first
to fire Aaron citing her recent absences
as the grounds for her dismissal even
then she still didn't seem to care the
fact she might not be able to make rent
barely registered returning home after
her other job called her in to tell
Aaron she would no longer be working
there either she instantly looked around
for Poncho 2 but it was nowhere to be
found all the photos on the walls having
faded Aaron checked her phone all the
original copies of the pictures were
gone too instantly racked with fear so
addicted to the plushy that she could
barely function without it she began
tearing her apartment to shreds looking
for it she wrenched cupboards off their
hinges and tipped over her refrigerator
flipping her mattress Aaron sliced the
fabric open with a kitchen knife
searching high and low for Poncho 2 but
unable to find it anywhere she became
frantic erratic pulling her hair out in
a fit of uncontrollable despair where
had it gone had someone stolen it Dr Lee
the paranoia had already set in
convincing Aaron that her therapist must
have taken Poncho too she was the only
other person who knew about about it and
had been so critical of her using it to
make herself feel better marching into
Dr Lee's office utterly enraged Beyond
Reason all Aaron could think about was
getting her stuffed animal back no
matter what she had to do the effect it
had on her was so powerful so potent and
addictive that living without it was
worth anything even another person's
life little did Aaron realize as her
hands grew wetter coated with more of Dr
Lee's blood after every bludgeoning
strike her therapist had no idea where
Poncho 2 was in fact she had nothing to
do with it Vanishing in the first place
it had disappeared all on its own along
with all the photograph copies Aaron had
printed arriving somewhere miles away
SCP 589 was ready to begin the whole
cycle again on its next victim it would
take on whatever shape it needed to
appease the desires of the very next
person to find it praying on their
vulnerability and making them total
toally dependent on it that was what it
did everywhere it went leeching off
people that it could easily manipulate
its presence and interaction would calm
SCP 589 victims helping to alleviate
their stress or make them feel better
about their deepest
insecurities before long these helpless
victims would be able to think of
nothing else feeling as if they were
unable to live without their Obsession
doll and every time that was when SCP
589 would make its cruel ress move it
would vanish leaving its prey in a state
of intense withdrawal with a calming
influence of SCP 589 absent from their
lives all of a sudden the infected
people would suffer from a variety of
potential psychological symptoms manic
depression psychosis uncontrollable
despair Dementia or an errands case
paranoia and a heightened sense of
aggression that caused her to murder Dr
Lee that was one of the earliest in a
Spate of similar incidents that had been
reported as SCP 589 traveled from town
to town its influence spread leaving
entire populations dead in its wake all
the while the stuffed animal fed on the
mental anguish that had caused its
victims making them pay the ultimate
price for their Obsession when you think
of the biggest most money-making
merchandised and capitalized game series
of all time there's only one franchise
that comes to mind Pokémon for the
entirety of its lifespan
Pokémon has been a financial Powerhouse
and every year the series seems to grow
in popularity and revenue whether it's
games cards a show toys or even Pokémon
branded clothes that you need you'll
have no difficulty finding a product
that appeals to you everyone knows
Pikachu's face and nearly every child
born within the past 20 years has had a
firsthand experience with Pokémon it is
in some respects inescapable if you hate
po Pokémon too bad because this little
electric Mouse runs the world and you'll
just have to sit back and deal with it
one could even say that Pokémon is
uncontainable which poses quite the
issue for the SCP Foundation who work
tirelessly to ensure that no facet of
life is withheld from its reach but the
foundation rarely deals with major
franchises beloved by millions upon
millions of people across the world and
for good reason to an anomaly tied in
with major franchise poses a lot of
problems on the containment side namely
its ability to spread uncontrollably and
without care being witnessed by
countless individuals before the
foundation comes up with a way to
contain it Global supply lines have to
be interrupted to prevent anomalous
products from hitting shelves corporate
Espionage committed and most of all a
massively expensive coverup operation to
remove said products from consumer hands
if the foundation had to deal with an
anomaly affecting the Pokémon franchise
there's no telling how out of hand it
would get before they'd be able to get a
handle on the situation but in 2019
that's exactly what happened today we're
going to be looking at SCP
5254 an anomaly dubbed got to catch them
all in the foundation's database the
year was 2019 the place Japan the home
country of the Pokémon franchise every
year since 2014 the Pokémon company has
help the festival named Pikachu outbreak
in the city of Yokohama in which
hundreds of costumed actors dressed as
Pikachu would crowd the city's Mirai
district and perform dance and even
participate in a parade the event was
intended to celebrate the Pokémon
franchise and promote whatever the
latest Venture the series is pushing
whether it's a game a movie or something
else the festival proved to be
successful and has been held every year
since after all who wouldn't want to see
a legion of Pikachu running a muuk
through the streets but the fun would be
shortlived during the 2019 outbreak
where something incredibly unusual
occurred picture this a large crowd
hundreds of fans dressed in Pokémon
themed attire standing on both sides of
the streets men women children anyone
and everyone came to see the Pikachu
outbreak and they weren't disappointed
parading down the street was a horde of
Pikachu just as advertised they danced
bounced and walked together in routine
fashion all while the crowd cheered and
yelled even the spectators in the crowd
showed their spirit with Pikachu themed
hats yellow Tails fastened to their
backs and yellow face masks with two
electrified red circles on the cheeks
the parade proceeded as normal that is
until one of the parading Pikachu
started behaving oddly it began as out
of sync movements strange wobbles and
deviations from the parade path for the
heavily coordinated outbreak Festival
this was was unusual the rest of the
Pikachu line danced to the Beat of the
Music sticking inform formation as best
as they could then as if pushed by an
invisible force the strange Pikachu
raced forward diving head first into the
crowd barreling into the group of people
and eventually colliding the crowd moved
out of the way slightly shocked no pun
intended by what had occurred but then
it happened again two more Pikachu ran
into the crowd and then again over 15
Pikachu ran themselves into the crowd
resulting in a massive disruption of the
parade and the shutdown of the event
entirely the foundation quickly caught
wind of this and sent their closest
operatives to assess the situation in a
controlled Fashion After blocking off
the crowd and shutting down the event
another strange detail emerged one that
ensured the foundation that there had
been some sort of anomalous significance
to what was occurring here some of the
crowd members involved in the collisions
were suffering very peculiar medical
injuries namely blunt force trauma way
stronger than what a clash with a
costumed actor would induce and severe
electrical burns the foundation was
positive there was something occurring
here and with the franchise as vast and
popular as Pokémon they didn't want to
take any chances immediately Foundation
agents began collecting information on
the event setting up probes in the
offices of game freak and the Pokémon
company and attempting to get to the
bottom of what exactly happened during
the parade
when the foundation interrogated the 15
mascots who collided with the crowd they
were shocked to learn that they weren't
mascots at all but instead fully
separate entities that resembled the
Pikachu costume x-rays revealed that
their once human skeletons were now
fused to their costumes and touching
them produced a minor electric shock the
performers had become Pikachu and now
they were unable to be removed from
their costumes every captured instance
had expired before the foundation was
able to to fully study and discern what
was occurring to them their bodies
unable to support themselves after such
a lethal extreme transformation later
observation found that the synthetic
components of the costumes such as the
cotton and plastic composits had fused
into their flesh and muscle tissue
bodily fluids were found to contain
foreign DNA and numerous strange
structures to the point where an
ordinary human's genetic makeup would be
incomparable and unrecognizable with
that affected by the anomaly
the foundation tentatively opened a file
on SCP
5254 the anomalous transformation of a
human into the rough approximation of a
Pokémon character and began carrying out
tests to determine what occurred during
the festival what caused SCP 5254 to
manifest it couldn't have been random
could it the foundation needed to know
one theory that the researchers working
on the SCP 5254 file had come up with
was that it was the large Gathering of
Pokémon related clothing worn by the
crowd that prompted the transformation
but that begged the question why hadn't
this occurred at any previous festivals
or large Pokémon related Gatherings it
was a huge franchise there were
absolutely more events that had masses
of costume fans Dawning Pokémon related
gear did something happen in recent
years to Manifest this anomaly the only
way to find out was to conduct testing
in one of the easier experiments that a
d-class Personnel was tasked with
carrying out the foundation ordered a
group of them to dress entirely in
Pokémon related clothing which the
foundation provided themselves some
items such as a full-bodied gavor onesie
were taken from Dr clef's Personal
Collection itself no he is not taking
further questions anyways with the
d-class looking utterly ridiculous in
full Pokémon getup the observing
researchers began their tests first was
a d-class outfitted solely in a Pokemon
Pikachu big face with ears hat as the
product's official title stated after
standing there for 15 minutes the
foundation determined that there was no
discernable effect next was a Pokémon
detective Pikachu cosplay mask latex
which the foundation placed on the same
d-class after another 15 minutes with no
changes observed the d-class closed the
experiment remarking that it was stupid
the research team told the d-class to
remain composed and to just continue
along with the trials unless they wanted
to be reprimanded after that was a Deon
adult onesie Pikachu animal pajamas a
few researchers held back laughter as
the hardened muscular declass in front
of them stood around in a Pikachu onesie
that barely fit him after asking him how
he was feeling the subject quickly
turned aggressive the results from this
test were deemed inconclusive due to
researchers being unable to determine if
the quick snap in Anger was as a result
of a potential anomaly or whether the
d-class was just getting fed up with
having to do this in my opinion this
test was hilarious for the next Test 2
de class classes were brought in clad in
Pikachu onesies the d-class were placed
4 M apart after a period of time a
tingling sensation was reported in the
arms and legs akin to that pins and
needles feeling you get when your arms
fall asleep or when you get shocked by
static electricity the next one had four
D classes all dressed similar to the
previous group instead of being meters
apart they were asked to hold hands
which the DCL classes begrudgingly did
severe migraines were reported as well
as throbbing pain in the cranium and
lower jaws of the face near the tailbone
some DCL classes reported a dull aching
most curiously several areas on their
body had begun to change in skin
coloration namely a mustard yellow
eventually the foundation began to test
for an affiliation or emotional
connection to the Pokémon franchise
could that be the key to understanding
SCP
5254 another 4D class all noted Pokémon
fan F were brought in one had owned a
copy of Pokémon Yellow for the Game Boy
when he was a child and another had a
high-leveled account on the Pokémon Go
app the foundation discovered that these
d-class reported muscle spasms along the
extent of their spines with one
complaining of tightness in their chest
before coughing up toughs of fur and
another physically recoiling upon an
attempt at physical contact in fear they
would electrically shock the researcher
these experiments proved to be fruitful
for the foundation as they learned that
SCP 5254 was irreversible removing the
clothing or items did not result in the
transformative properties of SCP 5254
reversing furthermore the testing went
on Beyond this point just to cover all
possible bases of what SCP 5254 was
before the details were properly ironed
out a total of 56 d-class Personnel were
lost during these experiments and
testing paus due to concern by
Foundation high-ups of a potential
security breach and damage being done to
the sight's power grid but most
importantly a connection to the Pokémon
brand was what enabled SCP 5254 to truly
take effect that's what occurred at the
outbreak festival with the bodies of
costume Pikachu Fanatics fused into
their costumes and barreled towards the
crowd now that the foundation understood
the how of SCP
5254 they still had to get to the why
even by Foundation standards this is is
a pretty odd and random anomaly did the
answers lie with game freak or the
Pokémon company itself after the
festival incident the foundation put web
probes into the servers of the Pokemon
company's Japanese branch and had their
web crawlers scann through millions of
Correspondence emails to find any hint
of unusual behavior a series of emails
between major shareholders in the
company were found the first was from
kimishima Tatsumi the CEO of Nintendo
the overseeing company above the Pokémon
company and sunak Kazu ishihara the
latter's CEO do not ask questions if
this Sur Viper wants Manpower for his
project give it to him our society will
not mess with these irrelevant
individuals he whoever he claims to be
may be charging us a small fortune but
at least he seems genuinely interested
in bringing our Creations to life
bringing their Creations to life how
curious the email was dated to 2017 2
years before the outbreak incident the
foundation decided to dig deeper another
email from 2017 exchanged between the
two individuals months after the first
Tuesday will'll Mark the fifth visit by
the Fukushima orphanage to our
headquarters I told the Press it's part
of our Global Outreach program to spread
the joy of Pokémon to the rest of the
world early results have been positive I
should have a specimen to show you the
next time we meet in Tokyo your daughter
likes Eevee yes it seemed like these
Executives were talking about creating
real Pokémon somehow what did the
orphanage have to do with this another
email read play anytime anywhere with
anyone yes the slogan for the switch is
very AP for what we're trying to
accomplish your marketing team deserves
a raise I pleased to report Pokémon go
has it 750 million unique downloads in
July and 5 million daily average users
this past week the popularity of the
franchise continues to grow think of the
possibilities once we integrate
augmented reality AR technology into the
project alaria as a clean and efficient
form of air transportation Charizard
serving in the self-defense forces and
yes Pikachu making our Reliance on
nuclear energy a thing of the past soon
Pokémon will come to life before our
very eyes the foundation could believe
something as absurd as creating real
Pokémon was a genuine possibility for
these companies it was going on right
beneath their noses but the email from
2018 began to show cracks in the Pokémon
company and Nintendo's plans the
accidents are growing in number are you
sure sir Viper has everything under
control we cannot hide these incidents
from the public forever we already have
our hands full trying to catch The
Runaways if we don't take action soon
more people will get hurt or Worse the
Pokémon brand will be tarnished forever
whoever was responsible for creating
Pokémon for the companies was going by
the Alias of Sur Viper and it seemed
like their experiments weren't working
the way they planned an email directly
addressed to Sur viiper fully
encapsulated the Pokémon company's
disgust at the individual once they
realized the experiments weren't
succeeding in creating an immersive fun
Pokémon experience in the real world you
promised us Pokémon as pets and
companions not these mutations I've had
to recall thousands of faulty
merchandise with tens of thousands of
defective products still circulating the
market just what kind of sorcery have
you forced Upon Our Hands the government
is breathing down my neck Tatsumi son
has had to resign and I'm starting to
hear about this Foundation poking around
tell me the truth is there any way to
reverse the effects or have you doomed
us all Sur Viper 1995 as their screen
name read responded with this I don't
know what to tell you I've given the
people what they want only true fans
will get a Pokémon of their own your
company was the very best at building
your brand congratulations today Pokémon
has taken over our hearts and Minds
perhaps one day we will see them take
over the world and with that the company
had cut off all communication with Sur
Viper but now the foundation had to get
to the bottom of what was happening in
these boardrooms and offices making
Pokémon in real life it sounded crazy
and from the way the emails were worded
they had apparently succeeded in making
something even if they considered it a
failure 3 months later after all of the
research on SCP 5254 was conducted the
overseer Council authorized a raid on
the Pokémon company offices in monado
City Tokyo on June 16th 2019 from the
way the emails were written they had
reason to believe that civilians were
potentially being held against their
will and used in these experiments
failure to deal with them now could
potentially spell disaster if they got
out and the cause of SCP 5254 wasn't
immediately neutralized following the
Japanese government's authorization of
the raid a foundation mobile task force
Detachment from Epsilon 11 nine-tailed
fox was stationed outside the offices
the task force broke into the building
through the fire exit and promptly
cleared out tourists and civilians from
the area during the raid they
encountered a large creature that
resembled the Charizard an orange fire
breathing dragon Pokémon that stopped
them in their tracks in the hallway
Wings an elongated snout the perfect
color it looked exactly as if a
Charizard had left from the screen and
into real life it spewed combustible
orange liquid at the team but they
quickly dispatched it with ease using
their weapons to put some water on the
Pokémon's fire well the water was
actually a salvo of bullets but the
metaphor still works most of the
building was cleared and those inside
detained for further questioning but
then the team came to a set of steel
doors inside was a room littered with
toys brightly colored walls and large
metal caves es inside the cages were
some of the most disgusting Creations
the team had ever witnessed Sur vipers
failed experiments clearly entities at
various stages of SCP 5254
transformation one resembled a Vulpix a
fox Pokémon it had engorged eye sockets
and blood flowing down their cheeks
another cage had a boy with cheekbones
protruding High ins sideways pulling
thin skin over the rest of his face
another had a large bear-like entity
with with serrated claws with alternate
fingers peeling and decomposing
underneath most horrifying of all were a
pair inside cages near the other side of
the room a girl with an extended
flattened engorged tongue which pulled
drool onto the floor at her feet she was
made to resemble a lick tongue a Pokémon
with a similarly large tongue another
was an elongated purple snake like the
Pokemon Arbok except its head was that
of a toddler it rides back and forth
balling and screaming the team requested
immediate medical pickup to remove the
specimens from the room wherever sir
Viper the individual responsible for
this was the foundation could not locate
them the foundation contained the
experiments and detained Mr ishihara the
CEO of the company it was brought back
to the research site for an interview
ishihara claimed not to know of the
experiment's existence but he quickly
broke down when asked about Sir Viper
ishihara had this to say we didn't ask
too many questions
when we found out what he had been doing
to the children we terminated his
contract immediately but the damage had
been done later we discovered he had
already tampered with our production
lines and distribution infrastructure at
this point it's impossible to tell which
products had been affected on the market
following This Global coordination
between Nintendo the foundation and the
Pokemon company in an attempt to figure
out a solution to products that were
affected by SCP 5254 is presently
ongoing all attempts to contact Sur
viiper 1995's email result in the same
automated message Happy Hunting but even
you can't catch them all there's an app
for that wait hold on I'm Steve
Jobs stop it it was a phrase so
ubiquitous in the early days of the
smartphone craze that it's hard to
believe Apple actually has trademarked
it was a testament to a simple and
immutable truth about the world these
new touchscreen phones were creating no
matter how strange and obscure the need
there would be an app to fulfill it
perhaps you remember iBeer the app that
allowed you to pretend you were drinking
a tall glass of beer for some reason
there was car M an app that reminded you
where you parked your car in a pirate
voice and who could forget I am bread a
surreal game about controlling a
sentient slice of bread on a quest to
become toast but there's one app out
there somewhere on the market that you
probably didn't download and if you did
well you have our sincerest apologies
because even seeing this video pop out
onto your feed probably sent a chill
down your spine well if that chill ever
even left take it from one gentleman
whose life took a very strange turn
after downloading a certain app that the
SCP Foundation calls SCP
1471 because the sentiment there's an
app for that doesn't exclude
experiencing mortal Terror Joe Lis an
insurance salesman from Milwaukee had
just gone through another atrocious date
after a mediocre meal and an
uncomfortable 35 minutes of an name
Babble sensing the whole time that she
really wasn't that interested his date
excused himself to take a quick phone
call outside sadly for Joe she never
returned leaving him to pick up the
check of all the many words you could
use to describe Poor Joe Lis the most
pertinent would be lonely ever since
Carol his wife wife of 10 years had
passed away in a freak accident he'd
been trying to find some kind of way to
fill the void they'd been high school
sweethearts intent on spending the rest
of their lives with one another as fate
would have it only Carol would get that
tainted luxury Joe would be forced to
endure life after the joy of living had
run its course he only hoped he might be
lucky enough to find love again however
Joe was on the wrong side of 40 and as
so many others his age were already
hitched he could feel his options going
out one by one would he be destined to
live out the rest of his days alone Joe
didn't feel like spending the back half
of his life catching reruns of Seinfeld
and tending to his fish he needed to get
out there and thankfully like the rest
of us he lived in the internet age he
had more apps websites online services
and hot Russian singles in his area than
he knew what to do with so surely one
would have the right person for him he
tried them all Tinder hinge match.com
Plenty of Fish e-harmony Bumble zus Okay
Cupid FriendFinder deeply lonely singles
with low expectations. comom and so much
more however all it seemed to achieve
was setting him up for more
disappointment none of the dates he'd
managed to get ever resulted in anything
getting serious heck it was a minor
miracle if he even managed to get any of
them on a second date was this it was
this his life now had he only ever
gotten one shot at l love and the
grasping claws of Fate yanked it away
from him without a second thought would
life continue on the hamster wheel of
loneliness sleeping getting up eating
working and sleeping again every day
getting somehow both faster and slower
as life trudged on to a disappointing
yet inevitable conclusion what a
terrible fate to find yourself trapped
in whenever Joe started feeling modlin
like this he knew it was time to get
proactive again maybe the right woman
was out there there were bill ions of
them after all surely at least one of
them would be the perfect person for him
he just needed the perfect app he'd burn
through all of the most reputable apps
already and was now perusing some of the
slightly seedier options most of which
were likely data mining fronts from the
Vulcans however as generic app after
generic app passed something different
caught his eye the icon was a smiling
cartoon dog and its name was Malo
version
1.0.0 hero this gave him a little
chuckle at the very least it was very
different branding from the rest of the
dating apps he'd seen maybe had just
been sorted into the wrong section of
the App Store he decided he'd check it
out and take a look at the app's
description the description read never
settle for those awkward feelings of
being alone ever again Malo is an
exciting and interactive experience that
will keep you engaged and intrigued the
anxiety of social situations can be
nerve-wracking but after just a few
hours of
you will soon forget all about those
painful emotions of disappointment be
part of the new craze that is quickly
becoming the next social substitute
remember the more you participate the
more Malo will engage you your
experience is completely up to you
absolutely no ads enjoy well it
certainly provoked Joe's curiosity at
the very least he did want to banish his
feelings of loneliness and seeing as the
app was free and apparently had no ads
he'd surely be foolish to not at least
give it a whirl what's the worst that
could happen he began the installation
and only then noticed that the app had
no listed developer it took up 9.8 MB of
memory which he wasn't Tech saavy enough
to see any issues with more than
anything Joe was just enticed by the
prospect of finally having another
chance at companionship with Malo after
all it is the next social substitute
whatever that means however Joe's
excitement was quickly quashed when he
hit the home screen button and noticed
that the icon for the app never actually
materialized strange he checked the App
Store portal again and saw that
according to them the app had completely
downloaded what gives was it a glitch or
was Malo actually just malware either
way he was disheartened by the fact that
this immaterial app certainly wouldn't
be getting him any companionship or so
he thought anyway Joe was used to
disappointment by now so he didn't take
it too personally he decided to just
play out the rest of his evening on
autopilot making himself some soup doing
the laundry watching more Seinfeld
reruns taking a cold shower and
preparing to cry himself to sleep again
Malo was already becoming a distant
memory just like all the deceptive
sources of home but one strange thing
happened that disrupted Joe's finally
tuned evening routine he received a text
message this was incredibly strange
because nobody ever seemed to text him
the last text got was from Carol just
before her accident so it was almost
surreal to hear that alert sound now
after everything that happened he
checked and saw that the text was an
image attachment sent from an unknown
number perplexed yet curious he decided
to open it his curiosity soon gave way
to a kind of melancholy Nostalgia when
he saw that the photo was of his and
Carol's favorite Cafe in town they'd
spent many a morning there back when she
was alive treating themselves to a nice
cup of coffee and perhaps a Quant just
seeing it again caused an involuntary
smile to spread across his face it never
even occurred to him as it probably
would have to others that this could be
seen as a little creepy he hadn't
frequented the bakery since Carol died
how would anyone even know that this
place held any significance for him was
it a stalker a ghost or just a spooky
coincidence none of these thoughts even
crossed Joe's mind he was just grateful
for the surprising reminder of the
happiness he'd once had for the next
couple hours things seemed lighter he
went about his evening checking the
photo every so often and smiling until
eventually he found himself in bed still
looking into the glow of his phone it
was such a beautiful little cafe then he
froze he noticed something in the
picture he'd been there the whole time
but only now he was seeing rather than
just looking it was in the corner
staring through the glass of the cafe
store so faint he almost wanted to
dismiss it as a trick of the light it
was a face well not a face more like a
skull not a human not anywhere near
human long slender and canine with
protruding fangs and vacant white eyes
the Pure White of the skull was buried
in a nest of thick black hair it looked
like it was crouching behind the door
looking out and grinning whatever the
hell it was just seeing it change the
entire tone of the picture it was no
longer a simple reminder of bygone Joy
now all that was radiating out of that
image was a palpable sense of dread was
someone playing some kind of awful prank
on him just then he was jogged from his
contemplation by another alert a new
message from the same number as before
with great hesitation he hovered his
thumb over the push notification and
clicked that's when everything got a lot
worse it was a photo of a bus stop not
just any bus stop of of course it was
stop c16 the one that Joe always took to
get to work it looked like it was taken
relatively early in the morning but
nobody was there well not quite nobody
there was that figure again it stood at
full height behind the partially frosted
glass that makes up the back of the bus
stop the same large black humanoid shape
with a white grinning dog skull where
the face should be something about it
terrified him on such a primal level
like the way our lizard brain reacts to
some ancient apex predator and whatever
this thing was it clearly knew something
about him how else could it stage all
these photos Joe got out of bed and
looked out at the window down onto his
dark Front Street empty thankfully but
after this surprise nightmare he wasn't
going to take any chances he grabbed a
kitchen knife from downstairs and placed
it on his bedside cabinet right next to
his phone with 911 on speed dial Joe Lis
a 43-year-old man slept with the lights
on that night for the first time in over
30 years sadly for him the nightmare was
just beginning the next morning Joe woke
up unharmed but he wasn't pleased to see
that he'd gotten several more texts in
his sleep there was one taken outside of
the local insurance company office where
he worked the strange creature with the
skull for a face was looming around the
corner peering at the camera with its
lipless grin like it was mocking him
another photo was taken at the local
supermarket where Joe did most of his
grocery shopping the frame was
centralized on the seral aisle bordered
on both sides by walls of garish mascots
endlessly repeated down at the far end
of the aisle was a looming dark figure
with that cold canine skull where a
human face should be there were a few
more but worst of all was the last one
it was taken at the cemetery in the
foreground a headstone reading Carol Lis
beloved wife and daughter
Joe was horrified to see that
skull-faced Beast was rising up behind
his wife's grave long clawed fingers
curling around the top of the headstone
that was the moment that Joe decided to
go to the police about all of this
before things got even more out of hand
he called an Uber to get down to the
station he certainly didn't feel like he
was going anywhere near his regular bus
stop after last night he showed the
photos he'd been sent so far to an
officer posted at the station and they
agreed that there was certainly
something strange about it while the
behavior undeniably bordered on
harassment it hadn't yet delved into
criminal territory so he would sadly be
on his own until then the best they
could do was stay in touch and kept a
breast of any new developments the only
Sage advice they could give him was not
to delete the photos as they could
always be used as evidence in cord later
if things escalated this was literally
the last result that Joe wanted out of
this considering how bizarre and
threatening things were getting already
he really didn't want to find out what
escalation looked like in this case but
what else could he do but carry on just
trying to exercise as much caution as he
could in these strange new circumstances
he went to work and tried his best to
stay productive despite the fact that
every 3 or so hours a new photo would
arrive places that he liked to sit in
the local parks stores he'd frequent
restaurants he liked to eat at the
nightmare skeleton dog thing would be
standing in all of them just mugging for
the camera on one hand every time he
looked at one of the photos Joe felt
like he was giving this freak exactly
what they wanted on the other hand how
could he possibly Look Away what if he
missed something that could save his
life it carried on much like that until
later in the evening Joe may have not
been a genius but he was no fool either
he'd seen too many of those CD true
crime documentaries about kidnapping to
take his normal route home he took a
real detour frequently checking over for
his shoulder the entire time much to his
relief he didn't see anything out of
place good when he got home he locked
every door and bolted every window
nothing would be getting the jump on him
tonight that's when the next picture
came in a photograph of Joe's empty
office cubicle with the Bony face of the
creature looming over the divider with a
grin he could feel his heart pounding
away in his chest just looking at it how
did this thing get around like this how
was it able to infiltrate every where in
his entire goddamn life suddenly he felt
a smile spreading across his face this
freak had just messed up big time before
all these creepy photos had been taken
in public places but the one taken in
his office oh this crossed the line into
trespassing the police would have to do
something about it now it had given him
an ace up his sleeve that confidence
faded a few hours later when he received
another photo this time it was the
skullface monster just standing on the
sidewalk the sidewalk that Joe
remembered walking on his covert
alternative route he could feel himself
break into a cold sweat it seemed
whoever this was he really did hold no
secrets from them now more than ever Joe
didn't feel safe in his own home so you
can only imagine how he felt when a few
hours later he received a photo of the
skull-faced stalker standing right
outside his own front door staring into
the camera it sent him rushing to the
window again to check outside but of
course nobody was there the next day
when he called the police and updated
them on the situation they told him that
they were doing all they could the best
thing he could possibly do was to remain
calm but Vigilant he needed to keep an
eye on the photos being sent to him so
he could notify them if ever he was in
any immediate danger this put poor Joe's
paranoia at a fever pitch even when he
went to work surrounded by his
co-workers by Witness es he could
scarcely tear his eyes away from his
phone he was a slave to the photos
forever waiting for the next one only to
experience crushing regret when the
photo actually arrived it looked like it
was taken moments before it was sent to
him Joe saw himself looking at his own
phone in his office cubicle with that
huge skull-faced figure looming behind
him he screamed out loud upon seeing it
and turned to see if anything was behind
him but of course there was nothing
there the police inspected the office
talked to potential Witnesses and
analyzed the photo it showed no signs of
any photographic manipulation but there
were also no witnesses around the office
who claimed to see anything strange that
day there was also no security camera
footage in the last several days that
showed this figure coming in or out Joe
lilis started to feel like he was going
insane and perhaps he was but that
didn't change the tangible and ever
present feeling that he was in great
danger he didn't come into work the next
day he'd received more photos like that
in the night of himself taken in real
time with that skull-face freak looming
he didn't want to leave the house he
didn't want to go anywhere anymore he
just didn't feel safe out there how
could he with all this madness unfolding
there was a time where he could have
said something like at least it only
seems confined to my phone he might have
even suspected that it had something to
do with that strange malow app he
downloaded a few days prior that hadn't
seemed to do anything but this situation
had evolved since then he wasn't just
seeing the creature in photos anymore it
was here he kept seeing quick flashes of
it on the other side of Windows in
Reflections in the corner of his eyes
always darting away if ever he turned
towards it it was everywhere and nowhere
it was here just for him he just knew
the police couldn't help nobody could
help
Joe just sat in the corner of his
bedroom clutching his kitchen knife
afraid to close his eyes he could be
anywhere it could be anywhere it could
be anywhere we know one thing for sure
Joe Lis never felt truly alone ever
again he always had his new friend
waiting just out of sight and if ever
you're feeling Lonesome and decide to
download Malo version 1.0.0 yourself
then you'll never feel lonely again
either who doesn't love their pets right
whether it's a dog a cat a goldfish or a
hamster any pet owner will tell you that
their furry friend is so much more than
just an animal that they adopted to many
pets become permanent additions to the
family well they might not look like a
human being or even have the ability to
speak the way we do a lot of owners view
their pets as people in their own right
of course a person can't be a pet at
least a human person can't right well
not unless you happen to be a part of
SCP
1897 otherwise known as the human
domestication Society if you've ever
been brave enough to travel alone to the
rural parts of Southwestern States like
Arizona New Mexico Texas Oklahoma Utah
or Nevada then it's likely you would
have been an ideal victim for SCP
1897 this designation doesn't refer to
one single creature or entity but rather
a group of similar beings witness
testimonies and photographs of SCP 1897
depict them as humanoid creatures
standing approximately 5 m in height
these beings have displayed a speed and
strength far beyond that of any human
they are capable of traveling roughly
200 m in only 9 seconds and lifting
weights of up to 500 kilos with a single
hand these entities are not Immortal and
can be harmed by conventional means but
that doesn't mean it's an easy task any
SCP 1897 instance that is killed or
incapacitated immediately vanishes
resulting in them dropping anything that
they may have been carrying at the time
and surprisingly these are not mindless
monsters and actually appear to be
capable of communication furthermore
they do not seem to speak a unique or
distinct language but instead
communicate in standard American English
with accents and vernacular approp to
the regions they appear in however they
will actively refuse to reply to any
human that attempts to engage them in
conversation now these creatures don't
spend every waking hour of the day
roaming around the states of Texas
Oklahoma and all the others we listed if
they did it's likely a lot more
civilians would have spotted them by now
and would probably live their lives in
fear of these gigantic 5 m tall
humanoids but instances of SCP 1897 will
only manifest if certain specific spe
ific criteria are met and these are as
follows to encounter SCP
1897 a person must be alone or part of a
group of no more than two if more than
one person is with them then no
manifestation will occur there is one
exception to the rule if a child under
the age of 12 is present secondly
neither the person nor anyone with them
can be carrying any kind of weapon that
means no knives no guns not even pepper
spray third and finally they must be at
least 25 M from a major population
Center and what happens when all of
these conditions are met and one of
these creatures appears anyone
witnessing their arrival will notice the
creatures materializing appearing to
emerge from some form of unseen vehicle
when they manifest the SCP 1897 entities
are almost always carrying long poles
with large Nets at the end as well as
steel cages and are often seen wearing
dark green unit uniforms in most cases
they will attempt to capture any nearby
person in a way that causes them the
least possible harm should an SCP 1897
creature successfully apprehend a person
and place them in a cage both them and
their captive will vanish in a similar
manner to the way the creature appeared
all attempts to track SCP 1897 or one of
its abductive victims have failed there
is no way to know where they are taken
but as far as what happens to them that
we do have a little more insight to
sometimes although it is a highly rare
occurrence the captured human victims
May reappear around a month after their
capture while never in the same location
as where they disappeared from they will
always be accompanied by an SCP 1897
instance and will stay close by the
creatures side at this point the
abductee is barely human anymore they
are considered an instance of what is
known as SCP
18971 what signif I this sudden and
drastic transformation for one these
victims are always found to have been
forcibly castrated or sterilized
essentially no longer able to reproduce
the way humans naturally do for another
these instances of SCP 18971 universally
display a decreased level of cognitive
and mental function what we mean is that
their brains do not function the way
they should anymore instead these
abductees exhibit the same level of
intelligence and capability as the
average canis lupus familiaris otherwise
known as the common domestic dog should
someone attempt to rescue a person that
has become an instance of SCP
1897-1899 creature that accompanies them
they will be met with outward
animalistic aggression from the victim
it has been discovered by the SCP
Foundation that these behaviors can be
treated with amnestics unfortunately
though the process of an abducted person
becoming an SCP
18971 instance seems to be the result of
an invasive medical procedure known as a
lumbotomy this typically involves
removing or disabling certain parts of
the human brain meaning that what has
been done to these victims is permanent
and cannot be reversed so who is doing
all of this why are these creatures
collecting innocent human beings only to
reduce them to little more than animals
the answers lie in something currently
referred to as SCP 18
97-2 not another creature or entity not
an anomalous artifact or location with
strange properties but a website found
at the address
www.hd society. goov according to the
information on this site it belongs to a
group calling themselves the human
domestication Society the website
features Pages such as adoption training
breeding programs volunteering and more
the fact that this is the kind of
website you might expect to be about
dogs or cats but instead focuses on the
domestication of humans is certainly
enough to turn the stomach as we said at
the start of the video surely a human
being can't be somebody's pet right
wrong at least as far as the human
domestication Society goes their website
contains everything and anything one of
these SCP 1897 creatures could ever hope
to learn about owning a human as a pet
has your Human been misbehaving need to
train them to use the toilet these Pages
have all the information you need to
help your human become the most
well-trained human on your block boast
the training page of
www.hd society. goov the remainder of
the page contains links to various
articles such as obedience training
which claims an owner of a human can
show them who's boss without the need
for physical violence also featured are
mentions of how to toilet train or play
fetch with a human how to introduce a
human to others due to them naturally
not not getting along perhaps most
chilling of all is one article titled
understanding what your human wants that
warns human beings shouldn't talk and
another dealing with Strays offers tips
for anyone wanting to learn to capture
their own pets themselves it doesn't
seem like too much of a leap to think
that the SCP 1897 creatures have
followed a lot of the advice from this
particular article arguably worst of all
is an image featured on the website of a
tall men s SCP 1897 entity brandishing a
picana electrica this device for any
unfamiliar with the term is a form of
high voltage electrical cattle prod
normally used for the purposes of
torture in the photograph in question
the creature is wielding one of these
while standing sternly over a helpless
captive human male now an instance of
SCP
18971 with tears in his eyes further
Pages found on
www.hd society .ov recommends solutions
to certain human behaviors for example
like one might expect to find on other
Pet Care websites some of the human
domestication society's articles pertain
to dealing with aggression grooming
house training and even toilet training
then there's the adoption page which
states we offer a large variety of
humans for adoption every single day
while we cannot guarantee a human UC
listed on our website will be available
when you reach the shelter our invent is
updated every half hour we cannot answer
any questions about specific humans
pictured on our website over the phone
or email it is still unclear whether or
not the SCP 1897 creatures that have
been known to appear in the southwestern
United States are sent out to gather
humans and Mass to offer for adoption or
whether these creatures are individuals
trying to obtain human pets on their own
of course the worst conceivable answer
is both the site is horrifyingly
comprehensive with links to an actual
human ownership convention with panels
on breeding and preventing illegal human
poaching and skinning it's safe to safe
that you were ever unlucky enough to
read this website it would Haunt You for
Life naturally the SCP Foundation has
made several attempts to contact the
owners of this website they tried in
vain to communicate through the official
channels about SCP 18971 adoption as a
way of peacefully negotiating that the
human domestication Society website be
shut down as well as as its practices of
capturing lumbotomy breeding and
adopting humans however these
communication attempts were met with
silence that is until a message was
received by the foundation at site 06
addressed to a member of personnel that
does not exist no data pertaining to the
physical location of the sender could be
derived from the email but it was traced
to the same IP address as the human
domestication society's website the
email read as follows we will not listen
to your lies any longer it was you who
came after us first you who tore holes
in our world and tried to annihilate us
you who took our olive branch of peace
and fashioned it into a spear you who
nearly drove us to Extinction and now
that we have the advantage you attempt
to patronize us with your crocodile
tears we will not be deceived again but
unlike you we are not monsters we have
much anger towards your kind but we are
willing to forgive but first you must be
willing to change slavery and genocide
are immoral and not even you deserve
such a fate it is our belief then that
this alternative is a fair compromise
between guaranteeing our safety and
allowing your kind to live this is our
Mercy to you look at the humans who have
gone through our program see how much
happier they are your correspondence
tells us that you have seen them see how
much they love us why then do you
continue to to be defiant someday you
will thank us please try to understand
that this is for your own good for now
there is little that the SCP Foundation
can do to prevent the human
domestication Society from abducting
human beings to sell us pets to other
SCP 1897 creatures civilian access to
the HD society. goov website has been
restricted so we recommend you stop
typing into the search bar of your
browser to go take a peek yes we mean
you you seriously stop that as for the
entities that have appeared in the rural
areas of the southwestern States all the
foundation can do is position its agents
nearby in the hopes that they can detain
and neutralize the SCP 1897s as they
appear with lethal Force if necessary at
present the only procedure for any human
pets that are successfully recaptured is
to have them moved safely to containment
until a way of rehabilitating them is
found so far there hasn't been any luck
on that front you're a child awake at
night what a feeling in your room you
cling to these rare hours of the evening
and watch the hour hand crawl closer
towards the parts of the clock you've
never seen touched now you stare out
your window embracing the moon the stars
and the Darkness that engulfs them you
trace an owl's hooh hoos up towards the
densest Evergreen in the neighborhood
you see a rat Scurry across the top of a
brick wall you wave to your new
nocturnal friends bonded by the
preference of night now you open your
window and inhale smelling the dark sky
like chocolate cake you hold it in as
long as you can very soon you know it
will all be taken from you not by a God
or a black hole or any of the universe's
hypothesized collapses at this age you
know nothing of physical cosmology you
know nothing of the Book of Revelation
you're just a child the forces that give
and take from you are not understood
through physics nor philosophy nor
through numbers nor thought experiments
look at you your thumb is still pruned
from having just kicked the habit of
sucking it your pajamas are still one
unified piece of clothing cradling your
entirety with fuzzy cotton your teddy
bear is still an extension of your arm
not yet removed by maturity you're still
another 15 years from believing your
life is dictated by astrological signs
or personal free will or mathematical
outputs it's not that you're ignorant in
fact you're quite bright as a child you
don't bother to comprehend the forces
outside your house because you know as
long as you are living inside it they
have no governance the only true comes
from within from the two Gods you have
seen with your very own eyes sitting on
the ripped sofa in Gray sweatpants
watching a show about rich people
drinking mimosas on boats in the
Mediterranean the almighty parents
rulers of everything and with just one
compound word called up the stairs they
have the power to take everything away
from you bedtime and suddenly the
curtains are pulled over the world you
long for now it's not the stars but the
ceiling you're staring at but thankfully
You are not alone you pull your teddy
bear out from its hibernation beneath
your armpit and you hug him gently
careful not to squeeze out his stuffing
laying there you can't help but wonder
how your bare God like this so beaten
and bruised torn up like a dog toy one
eye dangling from a string his left leg
bends forward impersonating The Joint
structures of a flamingo yet as far as
you know your best pal has done nothing
but sleep how is he so battered can
hibernation be that taxing do teddy
bears expire the questions for now must
be ignored you lay there together in
your bed fighting the feelings of
Slumber almost as if rebelling against
Mom and Dad's tyranny thinking deeply
only makes you sleepier and tonight you
insist on staying awake it's 9:30 and
you've yet to be sucked into a dream and
that in itself is a small victory but
your parents' wishes will not be evaded
that easily if ever they fight back by
turning on the air conditioning the soft
rhythmic humming of the White Noise
weighs on your eyes and soon you can't
resist it any longer sleep sneaks up on
you the Battle Is Lost a safe 10 minutes
later your parents poke their heads into
your room and see your body stiff and
motionless wrapped in sheets like a
mummy they celebrate their Victory with
a quick kiss and go back to the sofa to
rest like Gods on the seventh day and
While You Were Sleeping dreaming of a
tomorrow where you don't surrender to
the same Powers there is yet another
battle to be fought and if all goes well
you'll sleep right through it but some
children won't be so lucky on July 7th
2001 a Portland Oregon news headline
reported a young boy missing from home
in the middle of the night his parents
were quick to respond that their son
wasn't the type of boy to go wandering
out into the dark and that something
suspicious was sure to be discovered
there in his bedroom the first thing
noticed was his stuffed animal a jovial
Orca torn to shreds its stuffing
scattered across the carpet its head and
body were stationed in the corner
nearest the bed soaked in a black
substance similar to Ink its eyes damp
with water the boy however was not to be
found as the parents held their son's
dismantled Orca in their hands feeling
the weight of mortality they comb their
fingers through the stuffed animals
organs as if giving it an impromptu
autopsy trying to determine what kind of
beasts could have done this but it
wasn't Justice for the Orca they were
after by the time we are old enough to
be parents we've outgrown empathy for
our inanimate counterparts for them the
orode was simply a representation of the
cruel faith that may have also been
bestowed on their child its death was
only respected for how it related to the
living and so the poor Ora was set aside
forgotten about until investigators
called upon the foundation to intervene
at which point MTF Iota 12 were
dispatched it revealed that the young
boy's room had large Trails of viscous
black liquid streaking the walls the
very same liquid found on the Orca but
where did this liquid come from
unfortunately there was no camera
footage to give us the answer neither
were there eyewitness reports or any
residual signs of what specifically
occurred neighbors who were awake
reported hearing the Thump Thump
thumping from the room which as expected
was useless by standard Insight leading
to nothing more than a series of rumors
and speculations maybe it was an
extremely localized earthquake maybe he
was just throwing a temper tantrum but
where does maybe this maybe that lead us
to can factual answer answers ever come
from this level of uncertainty well one
specific maybe just maybe the key to
cracking this case allow me to explain 2
days after the event the child was
rediscovered unconscious behind a hedge
in the family's Garden a brief interview
revealed that the child witnessed the
final minutes of what he described as an
intense battle he claimed my Orca was
fighting a big monster and then the
monster grabbed me and took me out the
window but someone saw it so it dropped
sted me and I hid in the bush a second
interview revealed no other discoveries
but the child claimed that the monster
ate his socks initial reactions to the
two interviews were as expected adults
reason the claims were imaginary a
fabrication of the child's mind
manifested to protect himself from
whatever the real trauma endured
actually was but heard beneath the
skeptical murmurs of jaded grown-ups
enslaved by their narrow perceptions was
one individual who dared to suggest
maybe just just maybe the boy is telling
the truth and it was in the spirit of
this hopeful and trusting maybe that the
foundation would prove the boy's story
to be truth and the truth would be known
as SCP
6330 SCP 6330 is a phenomenon affecting
stuffed animals worldwide though it is
most common in teddy bears manifestation
of this phenomenon is referred to as a
sleepwalker event occurring only within
the households of families with young
children typically between the ages of 1
to 14 while you're asleep vulnerable to
what lingers awake your favorite stuffed
animal may find life impulsively
combating enemies referred to as SCP
63302 these creatures typically blend
with shadows though this mechanism is
poorly understood they somewhat resemble
creatures associated with fantasy such
as dragons or ogres always manifesting
beneath your bed no matter how messy or
clean it might be SCP 63302 instances
depict Behavior indicating that they
intend to hurt or prey upon the sleeping
child and it isn't nightlights or
security systems that stop them but
rather SCP 6330 d1s SCP 63301 are
stuffed animals already present in a
child's room that seemed to be
nonanomalous prior to SCP
63302 manifestations SCP 63301 has been
shown to instantaneously manifest small
wooden Weaponry in order to combat SCP
63302 to protect their child battles
have been shown to last upwards of 20
minutes and are always near silent there
is an unspoken agreement between both
sides to keep their history concealed as
best as they can in observed cases SCP
63301 have emerged Victorious though are
severely wounded during the Skirmish
torn wool and stuffing are common and
following all known events SCP 63301
have died due to their injuries but only
after sacrificing themselves for the
safety of the child prior to death the
instance will drag the SCP 6330 d2's
corpse back under the bed frame and Dem
manifest to understand this the
foundation has conducted just one test
given the volatile nature of recreating
the events the foundation did not push
their luck with subsequent studies and
so it's the lone research done in 1987
on site 44 that they still lean on to
this day to understand SCP 6330 and the
instances that come with it it began
with a researcher volunteering his
7-year-old daughter henceforth referred
to as subject to be placed in a humanoid
containment room and Soo to sleep using
a teddy bear that she had a strong
emotional attachment to for 12 straight
tests our subject was observed to sleep
through the night peacefully her
environment remaining in alignment with
the trivialities of deep sleep but on on
the 13th study something would happen
something very unsettling even for the
foundation standards MTF Iota 12 were
stationed at the room's entrance for
Swift intervention if needed and until
that 13th attempt they felt their focus
to be pointless approaching the third
hour however they felt a subtle and
unexplained value in their presence they
felt something coming on that feeling
while danger is looming that feeling
that makes you clench your fists just in
in case and just as they made eyee
contact with one another to acknowledge
this shared feeling within the group a
quiet rustling sound Was Heard beneath
the bed and sounds reminiscent of a
large animal's breathing became audible
suddenly a pair of large scaly clawed
hands grasp the rim of the bed frame a
creature resembling a western Dragon
emerged but was it actually a dragon
were the sheets ready to be blasted to
flames if slain would the next regrow
and multiply by the hundreds these
thoughts raced through MTF Iota 12's
head one member instinctually ran for
the door to go protect the child but he
was held back and restrained reminded
that the success of the experiment was
dependent on letting the situation play
out naturally he was hard to console
patients at this moment did not feel
like a virtue it felt irresponsible a
creature standing approximately 3 m
above the ground switching between
bipedal and quadrapedal motion was
stalking a sleeping child and they were
instructed to simp watch for 5 minutes
the SCP 6330 D2 patrolled the room
moving silently and methodically unaware
of the surveillance cameras then SC SCP
63302 turned towards the subject
positioning itself at the foot of the
bed stretching its arms out towards the
subject it gaped its jaws wide exposing
rows of large pointed teeth and a dark
pink tongue it looked like a snake in a
field of mice as it prepared to Lunge at
the subject MTF Iota 12 was ready to
intervene but before they could the
stuffed bear stood up on the subject's
chest and Drew a small sword and shield
from an unknown source almost magically
like switching weapons in an old Zelda
video game it positioned its swords tip
downward and held its Shield at its side
SCP
63301 hunched over slightly and twirled
its sword maintaining eye contact with
SCP
63302 the entire way through after 10
seconds the SCP 6330 D2 threw its jaws
at the subject and SCP 63301 responds
with a leap towards the subject's
attacker slicing SCP 6330 d2's eye the
SCP 6330 D2 responds with a quiet Grunt
and touches its wound which leaks a
viscous black liquid the SCP 63301 jumps
towards SCP
63302 and mid battle uses fabric from
the bed sheets to quickly Stitch the
wound attempting to minimize mess and
proof of its presence both instances
went to battle for 9 minutes before the
first signs of damage to SCP
63301 following the severing of one of
SCP 6330 d2's dorsal spikes it strikes
the SCP 63301 with a heavy slap which
sends SCP
63301 across the room it stands back up
placing a hand on its stomach and looks
at its hand which is now covered in wool
and stuffing they charge at each other
once again but as the subject moves
slightly in her sleep both instances
stop and quickly agree on peace until
the subject settles when that happens
the instances resume fighting research
notes that while the battle is genuine
there is an element of guidance they do
not follow a script but it appears they
follow a code while both anomalies
welcome the conflict brought on by the
other neither wants it broadcasted to
the public after 20 minutes of battle
both instances are heavily scarred and
injured after kicking itself off of the
SCP 6330 d2's nose SCP 63301 Sprints
from one side of the room towards SCP
63302 leaping into the air and Landing a
fatal blow slicing the neck of the other
instance which Falls lifeless to the
floor SCP 63302 is dragged by the SCP
63301 back under the bed a short while
later the SCP 63301 emerges damag
sustain includes loss of one buttoned
eye exposed stuffing and torn wool it
places its sword and broken shield on a
nearby nightstand SCP
63301 then drags itself up the bed
sheets towards the subject who is
sleeping peacefully throughout the test
it rests beside the child lying
motionless it seems to glare directly at
the camera and a small digit protrudes
from its round hand giving a thumbs up
to the researchers its head flops onto
the child's cheek before ceases to move
the father who risked his daughter for
research is pleased with the discoveries
regarding both anomalies but it brings
about a new set of questions concerning
children and their relationship with the
dark these very thoughts you might even
wonder yourself maybe a kid's desire to
stay up past bedtime isn't so much about
wanting to watch cartoons with curse
words or read Calvin and Hobs maybe it's
not about a desire to be awake at all
but rather a subconscious fear of being
asleep maybe our senses as children are
heightened to the anomalies that creep
about maybe all the fabled fears of
children aren't Fairytales after all and
maybe Mom and Dad checking under our bed
is just performance parenting because
even if something were there would they
even be able to see it or is everything
Beyond an adult's understanding
misattributed to the imagination as we
age does our perception of how reality
should look alter the reality that is
actually there do we indeed see clearer
with our expensive glasses from our
high-rise office space or did we see
more accurately in the glow of our
action figure NightLight spying through
stitches in our blankets looking past
crusty eye boogers at what moved in the
shadows it is hard to ever know for
every real encounter a child has with an
SCP 6330 there might be hundreds of
falsehoods the ratio is truly impossible
to calculate but as long as teddy bears
are Universal so too are their anomalous
enemies and so where does that fact
leave us how do we go forward should we
be afraid to put our children to sleep
afraid of the monsters under their bed I
don't think that's what our hero would
want sometimes we have to learn to trust
things even if we don't understand them
like gravity or multiplication we have
to trust that the relationship between
children and their stuffed animals are
in fact real we have to learn their
loyalty is reciprocated even if the
adult world has Tau taught us otherwise
and if we ever need a reminder of these
lessons we can look to event 184 in
Cambridge England where we have our
first recording of a sleepwalker event
outside of controlled testing and also
our first piece of evidence proving SCP
63301 to understand language and how to
use it to connect with humans in ways
Beyond being cute and cuddly on November
11th 2008 a call was filed to local
authori by a family who claimed to have
discovered footage of a sleepwalker
event within their son's room mobile
task force Iota 12 lucid dreamers were
dispatched to investigate immediately
the footage was seized by personnel and
all members of the family were
administered Class A amnestics the
child's bed swayed lightly as an
instance of SCP
63302 emerges the instance resembles an
unknown creature though it is described
as having a large muscular frame the
instance walks to the opposite end of
into the room hunching over and
observing the child for exactly 10
minutes as the SCP 63302 begins to stand
further upright it extends a retractable
set of claws then the child's teddy bear
suddenly stands drawing a bow and quiver
SCP 63302 assumes a quadrupedal stance
and snarls before lunging Towards the
bed the SCP 63301 fires a single Arrow
towards the SCP
63302 striking the instance directly in
its canine like snout SC SCP 63302
responds with a loud Huff reminiscent of
that of a bull or Bine the instances
battle for approximately 30 minutes the
longest recorded Sleepwalker event to
date both show abilities and skill sets
consistent with other SCP
63301 and-2 instances eventually SCP
63302 has SCP 63301 pinned to a nearby
wall and tries to strangle it the SCP
6330 D2 then pulls one of scp's 6330
d1's arrows from its arm plunging it
into the d1's chest then the dash2 leans
its head towards the dash1 and Whispers
into the instance's right ear though
audio recordings cannot determine
exactly what was vocalized the SCP 63301
lifts up its head staring blankly into
SCP 6330 d2's eyes it reaches behind its
back pulling out a small entirely wooden
Glock 19 handgun the bear points the
weapon into SCP 6330 d2's forehead and
fires the shot is silent and the SCP
6330 d2's body falls limp black viscous
fluid sprays onto the wall the SCP 63301
hauls SCP 6330 d2's corpse Towards the
bed noticeably limping it drags the body
by its large forearm and Dem manifests
upon reaching the underneath of the bed
SCP
63301 returns and briefly stares around
the room before turning to the child it
climbs up a desk and finds a piece of
paper and a pen it goes on to write the
following note hello Timothy thank you
for always taking care of me it really
was fun I was able to repay the favor of
protecting you unfortunately I am hurt I
need to go I'm too weak to stay and I
just hope you'll remember me it's been
fun helping you I've enjoyed my time
under your care going into this I knew
it would happen the Sleepwalker is
coming for you I'm just happy I could do
my job goodbye my friend I hope I may
see you soon who doesn't love dogs
they're friendly energetic and can be
beneficial to their owner's happiness
and mental health on top of all those
positive qualities most dogs are
fiercely loyal to their masters you'll
often hear stories of dogs defending
their owners or even staying by their
side through their very last days and
even sticking next to them Beyond Death
as sad as that thought might be to many
dog owners it provides us the perfect
context for today's topic it's about
time you met SCP
1111 sometimes also known by the
nickname the white dog this moniker
actually refers to one of the two halves
of SCP 1111 namely the former SCP 111
11-1 while its counterpart is simply
known only as SCP 1111 -2 as you may
have already deduced SCP 11111 is or at
least appears to be a fairly common
domesticated dog sporting white fur that
gives it its nickname the white dog is a
cross between two different popular
breeds the German Shepherd and the
labrador retriever however upon closer
inspection this particular pup is a far
cry from one you might see fetching
sticks or chasing squirrels at the park
for one this dog never eats or drinks
under normal circumstances that would be
worrying behavior in any dog but in SCP
11-11-1 case it comes second to the fact
that this dog is partially seethrough
now that's definitely not normal in
actual fact this Pooch is pretty far
from ordinary it seems to be at least
semi-translucent not quite as much as we
usually picture a ghost or hologram but
also not fully visible like a living
being in fact how clearly visible the
white dog is can vary depending on how
close it is to 111
11-2 any further than 500 M away and the
dog will gradually grow more and more
transparent but not fully invisible but
visibility isn't the only thing that
shifts with 11-11-1 distance from its
other half the size of the dog also
changes it remains standing at 150 CM
when directly beneath 111 11-2 and
gradually gets smaller the further and
further away from 111 11-2 it gets
finally there's its eyes SCP 11-11-1
possesses a distinct pair of glowing red
eyes the brightness and intensity of
which increase the closer it is to 111
11-2 so let's recap so far we have a
strange white dog with glowing eyes that
changes size and becomes more or less
visible the further it gets from a
secondary element but if the white dog
is SCP 111 11-1 then what forms this
second part of SCP 1111 well if you were
to look close enough at the white dog
you'd notice the red collar that it
wears around its neck and hanging from
that collar is a tag on which is printed
one single word loyal it's certainly A
fitting word to describe
11-11-1 why because SCP 111 11-2 is
presumably the dog's master or rather
its Master's dead body dressed in an old
worn business suit and formal dress
shoes SCP 111 11-2 appears to be a
deceased male of indeterminant age the
precise identity of this man has proven
next to impossible for foundation
researchers to determine the condition
of his suit and shoes have deteriorated
so much that it has been difficult to
even identify the original company that
produced the clothing worn by the corpse
as for his cause of death well that
unfortunately seems all too obvious
given that the 111 11-2 body always
appears the same way hanging from a tree
with a noose around his
Foundation staff observed the two parts
that make up SCP 1111 have noted that
111 11-2 will occasionally make quick
vient twitching movements these random
jerks and spasms of the corpse are
consistent with those exhibited by a
person who is dying from asphixiation
and often researchers have heard the
body making desperate gasps for air the
closer his white fured canine
counterpart is the more frequent and
violent these motions and sounds will
become it's almost as if scp1 7-2 has
somehow been trapped on the very brink
of death reliving those final moments
over and over again all while guarded by
his loyal white dog if left alone and
not interfered with the white dog will
lie down just beneath where its Master's
body is hanging the dog never sleeps nor
does it require any food or water and
does not even seem to breathe and as
long as Foundation research staff keep
their distance both parts of SCP 1111
seem content to remain in a docile state
to keep them contained the SCP
Foundation has established a 2 km safe
Zone around SCP 1111 keeping them
monitored through cameras attached to
weather balloons the restricted
enclosure is according to a public cover
story a weather monitoring station hence
the balloons no member of foundation
staff is permitted anywhere within a
kilometer of SCP 1111 unless they are
given express permission from a superior
member of the foundation should SCP 1111
11 -1 ever stray away from the tree
where its Master hangs though then the
area must be evacuated of all Personnel
until the dog returns to its normal
position however Foundation staff are
urged to be wary When approaching SCP
1111 because the white dog may well be
more ferociously loyal than any pet
emphasis on ferocious the moment that
11-11-1 becomes aware of anything coming
towards itself and its owner's body the
dog will become viciously hostile
regardless of the person or object
coming towards it the semic corporeal
canine will attempt to attack and
destroy the Intruder in this state the
white dog exhibits even more dramatic
physiological differences from a normal
domesticated dog video footage recorded
by the SCP Foundation shows that the dog
is capable of reaching incredible speeds
of up to 60 kmph which is of course
considerably faster than an average
canine the white dog can also reach a
height of 6 M When jumping up into the
air and has teeth and a bite strength
powerful enough to tear through armor
plating composed of 15 mm thick titanium
given the entity's speed aggression and
translucent qualities any attempts by
the SCP Foundation to neutralize the
white dog or even capture it for closer
examination have ended the same Grizzly
way for the staff members who tried the
creatures Fierce loyalty defending its
owner's body also make it incredibly
difficult for foundation staff to even
get close enough to SCP 1111 two to
properly study the remains as we said
before that loyal tag around the dog's
neck is certainly an accurate
description on a date which has been
redacted from its file an incident
occurred involving SCP 1111 and a team
that consisted of a number of foundation
agents this team had been ordered to
neutralize the white dog and transport
the anomalous animal to a containment
facility attempting to evade the
creature's direct line of sight the
agents approached the hanging body of
SCP 1111 11-2 from the north the
opposite direction to the way the dog
was facing possessing a sense of hearing
and smell far beyond that of a human
being the white dog was able to quickly
detect the agents approaching its Master
when the team got within 300 M of the
tree where the body was hanging the
canine set upon them tearing at clothing
and shredding protective armor with its
teeth in order to get to the agent soft
flesh underneath one of these agents
fled running as fast as they could from
the area but of course this was audile
move as the white dog quickly noticed
and began to pursue the foundation agent
with its superpowered speed as it chased
them the surveillance cameras recorded
SCP 111 11-1 decreasing in size becoming
harder to see with the naked eye the
further it ran from the tree the dog's
speed began to decline too the further
the dog got from the tree with the Noose
the less the body hanging from it seemed
to be spasming too when the white dog
had reached 900 M from SCP 111 11-2 the
corpse was seen to stop moving entirely
Frozen and stiff as one would normally
expected the CE body to be realizing how
far away it was from its Master SCP
11-11-1 froze appearing unsure for a
moment it turned to look towards the
body of its Master perhaps sensing that
the random jerks and postmortem
movements had stopped at this point the
dog howled and sprinted back towards the
tree causing the corpse of its owner to
begin twitching yet again footage of
this incident showed that the the white
dog was impervious to Conventional
Weapons and any rounds fired at the
canine by Foundation agents merely
passed through its ghostly body however
its claws and teeth were very much solid
and it was able to slaughter almost all
the agents save for the one who fled who
ended up being the sole survivor of the
encounter following this disastrous
Mission the 05 Council issued an order
that in order to protect the lives of
foundation personnel only remote
controled drones and Expendable d-class
Personnel would be be permitted anywhere
near SCP 1111 shortly after the previous
incident a group of d-class were sent
into the area around the tree where SCP
111 11-2 was hanging this time
approaching from multiple directions at
once but this only led to the same
results as the white dog began to
quickly move between each of the DCL
classes killing them one after another
only one D
83011 was able to make it close enough
to the corpse to make any noteworthy
observation
as they approached the hanging corpse of
SCP 111 11-2 seemed to slow its jerks
and twitches and the body did something
that had never been seen before it
opened its eyes it raised its arms
towards the approaching declass in what
looked like a welcoming hug only for D
83011 to be torn to shreds by the white
dog moments after cameras nearby picked
up more previously unseen movement
namely the owner's mouth moving almost
as if he was saying the words no down
boy but soon after the corpse fell limp
again and resumed its normal Twitches
following this the foundation have
theorized that the white dog could
possibly be contained by somehow
removing its Master's body from the area
some staff have also noted that SCP 1111
shares certain traits with SCP 023 a
similar anomalous creature also referred
to as the black Shu much like the white
dog the Shu also possesses a ghostly
canine form and appears to be the same
large dog like creature that is
referenced in ancient folklore from
throughout the British Isles according
to Legend the Shu appears to Travelers
at Crossroads serving as an omen of bad
luck impending disaster and is even
thought to be one of the hounds of Hell
itself s SCP 023 like SCP 1111 also has
anomalous abilities that focus on
Geographic space in the black Shuck's
case anyone it detects approaching it
will die or lose a member of their
family within a year researchers working
for the foundation believe that SCP 023
and SCP 11-11-1 could be related or even
instances of the same phenomenon a sort
of dog yin and yang but since they have
still as of yet been unable to capture
the white dog it has been impossible to
verify this the SCP Foundation will no
doubt keep trying though while testing
may have been suspended for the time
being they always know where to find SCP
111 11-1 beneath its Master's hanging
body guarding it for all eternity so
here's a statement that won't blow
anyone's mind the SCP Foundation is
really really really weird and we're not
even talking about the actual anomalies
they contain sure this top secret
organization puts in the time and the
effort to make sure menaces to society
like the heart to destroy reptile the
Scarlet King and even the horrifying bad
joke tomato stay behind lock and key but
sometimes you need to hold the mirror up
to yourself and see just what the heck
is going on I mean seriously think about
it this is an organization that uses
live human beings farmed from Death Row
as test subjects considering how rarely
the death penalty is actually employed
in the Western World these days you know
some shady strings are being pulled
there and what about the 05 Council the
leaders of Humanity's last line of
defense against anomalous chaos and
according to some accounts there are a
group of vain Petty and morally bankrupt
individuals who regularly use anomalies
like SCP 006 the mountain of Youth for
their own personal benefit and don't
even get me started on the actual
scientists working under the
foundation's payroll that's when things
start getting even stranger of course
there's Dr Jack brigh a man forever
changed by the chance interaction with
SCP 963 an anomalous Medallion and one
of Abel's deadly blades now he's an
immortal weirdo whose equal parts
brilliant and a total nuisance so much
so that there's an entire dedicated list
for bidding all of his xier antics then
there's Dr Alto cleff don't even try to
shake his hand given how much this x
gooc wildcard loves using violence to
solve his problems you may draw back a
stump he specializes in reality warping
anomalies often wields a ukulele cuz
he's just so darn quirky oh and he's
very likely the baby daddy to a teenage
nature Sprite after a delance with a
goddess or oh and um what about Dr
Charles Ogden gears sure he may not look
that strange to the naked eye he's a man
so dull and humorous that gray is
favorite color and he thinks sugar on
corn flakes is an act of unacceptable
decadence but he's got a whole lot of
strangeness under the hood like the fact
he's such an emotionally unavailable
father that his daughters across
Dimensions have formed a Splinter Cell
of the Serpent's hand where they work
under the collective sudonym The Black
Queen just to spite him Dr Dan through
acts of sabotage was personally
responsible for the worst scp096
outbreak in Foundation history leading
to the end of thousands of lives just so
he could receive clearance to terminate
the creature and he got that clearance
on the condition that the SCP Foundation
would be terminating him for his crimes
as soon as the goal is achieved and then
there's oh my gosh did someone dress a
dog up in scientist clothes oh my God
that's the cutest thing I've ever seen
oh this is just brighten my day okay
maybe I was being too harsh on the
foundation before who whose dog is this
excuse me sir that is extremely
inappropriate
wait you can talk of course I can talk
you do I'm Professor Kan pathos Crow one
of the SCP foundation's finest Minds in
the field of advanced Robotics and
biochemistry I have a level four
clearance for 343's sake I'm not some
common bloody mut oh my apologies
Professor Crow I wasn't aware you were a
while a talking dog well yes I imagine
there's a lot you don't know about me
isn't there um I'm a little embarrassed
to admit it but uh that's true Professor
Crow our data on you and your work with
the SCP Foundation is a little sparse
here take these files these should give
you a good primer okay I suppose we
better take this from the top then
Professor C pathos Crow among a lineup
of extremely eccentric researchers
somehow manages to rise to the very top
in terms of sheer strangeness to get the
most obvious fact out of the way yes
while he was once a human an anomalous
experiment did result in him being
turned into a Labrador Retriever how did
this happen may ask we have the same
question sadly Professor Crow is
incredibly reluctant to share any
details about this strange and
embarrassing incident so we're just
going to have to accept it for what it
is and move on everyone ready okay good
despite his strange appearance Professor
Crow is actually one of the more
scientifically qualified of the
foundation researchers it's no surprise
that because of this he has a relatively
close working relationship with Dr gears
so much so that he still refers to gears
by his early found Foundation code name
Cog a reference to both the legendary
Stern doctor's initials and a pun on his
iconic surname during one incident Dr
gears did tell Professor Crow to
terminate an anomaly that was for all
intents and purposes a human child if it
presented any difficulties this sour the
wholesomeness of that previous fact so
we'll swiftly move on once again Dr
gears is just terrible with kids like a
lot of foundation researchers Professor
Crow was personally head hunted by the
SCP Foundation after his academic work
in the fields of advanced Robotics and
biochemistry started Turning Heads This
was just for clarity sake back before
Professor Crow was turned into a
laborador professor Crow spends most of
his time working in Biore research area
12 where he studies a variety of
anomalies but his bookish nature also
earned him another interesting position
he's the SCP foundation's Chief
librarian where his encyclopedic
knowledge of anomalous technical
literature has made him a valuable asset
in archiving and organization this
balances out some of Professor Crow's
indiscretions it is important to specify
that Professor Crow is genuinely a
well-liked figure among his SCP
Foundation co-workers after all who
wouldn't love to work with an adorable
dog in a lab coat and glasses all day
but it's also important to note that he
is also somewhat mistaken prone with a
number of these mistakes putting him in
the crosshairs of his superiors
Professor Crow has come close to
outright termination several times
perhaps the most out of any prom minent
researcher currently working at the
foundation however to keep himself out
of the same Dead Man Walking category
that the thoroughly unpleasant doctor
Dan currently finds himself in Professor
Crow has a few aces up his sleeve
firstly he's got friends in the
administrative Department willing to
pull a few strings to keep him out of
Harm's Way hey maybe they're just very
Ardent dog lovers up there the other
thing that's kept him from being turned
into an extremely overqualified chew toy
for SCP 682 is the contents of His
Brilliant brain on many of the occasions
where the 05 Council have considered
terminating him he's demonstrated the
fact he possesses vital and often
Irreplaceable knowledge saving his furry
skin a perfect example of the kinds of
strange scrapes that Professor Crow gets
himself into is the incident in 2009
where without even realizing it he
somehow traveled through time and scared
The Living Daylights out of everyone the
details are best expressed here in
Professor Crow's own dictated notes 1802
2009 in my years working here there have
been few things which have irritated me
caused me physical harm yes caused me
undue stress yes caus me innumerable
amount of mental distress yes but few
things have just irritated me time
travel is one of them I went to bed on
the 15th of January year 2009 at 1:30
a.m. I woke up on February 18th at 9:26
a.m. of the same year I hadn't moved I
had only 9 hours of sleep and to me
nothing had happened then then after a
slightly confused day admidst the many
cries of I thought you were dead among
other things I might add I discovered
that I have been missing for the past
month and 3 days in that time Sophia had
completely taken over my duties though
she had halted all of my personal
experiments and was trying her utmost to
relocate me while keeping my
disappearance from the higher-ups
Apparently data expunged leaving me to
sleep in a small self-contained bubble
of data exped and making at least data
exped which was eventually ruptured by
data exped and sending me back to this
phase of space and time needless to say
I was slightly irritated to say the
least 2402
2009 it had me in quarantine for nearly
the past week observing me and running
tests to see if they can find any sort
of strange abnormalities with my
physiology my behavior my anything if I
had one more hand shoved up my nether
regions or forced to look at one more
bloody ink blot I'm going to flip out
and go rabid they'll say they'll stop
the quarantine soon and Sophia says the
hups still haven't caught on to anything
I suppose I'm lucky in that count
normally the only time they quarantine
something is when it's too dead to be
any sort of immediate security Hazard
still I guess I can see where they're
coming from if it were my decision I'd
probably force a quarantine too and
probably for longer at least they had
the decency to give me my clothes my PDA
and someone to dictate to 1203 2009 I'm
still here and I hate it day in day out
it's the same thing get up eat exercise
then simple observation until lunch then
more observation until dinner then
lights out not allowed anything other
than the things I already have and even
then I only got those because Sophia
felt bad for me I'm only allowed to use
them every day for an hour at most
otherwise they're also in observational
storage all this wasted time that I
could have been doing something
constructive something useful something
interesting but no I'm stuck here
because of a r Twist of f forcing me
into this monotonous hell they keep
telling me I'll be let out soon Liars
055 2009 they've seen fit to release me
I almost thought I was going to die in
there still it almost seems strange to
be out and about again but I do
appreciate being back in my own quarters
my own clothes and my beloved Walker
back by my side Sophia has taken good
care of the facility while I was gone I
think I might actually leave that to her
while I keep to my experiments she seems
to enjoy a great deal suits her
analytical mind all of my personal
experiments are still waiting for me
with the exception of the 040 test logs
they simply haven't posted their
findings yet stating that they needed my
approval first so I'll have to pour
through those the first chance I get I'm
interested in the progress she may have
made still there is a good deal of work
to be done and I am more than ready
enough to take it on after all I have to
make up for lost time don't I it's clear
that life isn't easy for poor Professor
Crow much like Dr brgh After
experiencing the mysterious event that
turned him into a dog Professor Crow is
both a researcher and an anomaly and
unlike the superficially subtle
presentation of Dr Brit's anomalous
nature it's hard to hide the strangeness
of a talking dog in human clothes this
bizarre interatial Zone he occupies
forces the foundation to keep him on an
extremely short leash no pun intended
seriously Professor it wasn't intended I
swear anyway the point is Professor Crow
isn't allowed to clock up off at the end
of the workday like his fellow
researchers do he's forced to remain on
site almost never appearing in public if
the professor wasn't the kind of person
who could easily get lost in his work a
situation like this would probably drive
him insane speaking of you're probably
wondering by this point other than being
the cutest researcher at the foundation
sorry Dr clef you're special in your own
way we promise what kind of work is
Professor Cain pathos Crow actually
known for around here Professor Crow's
most notable body of work is largely
based on an opinion that's pretty
controversial to hold around the SCP
Foundation he believes that they should
be actively utilizing anomalies that
aren't dangerous in order to further
their Collective goals an excellent
example of this is The Cordial
relationship he has with SCP 040 also
known as Evolution's child she's a
powerful reality warper who is able to
synthesize new anomalous life from
pre-existing living creatures Professor
Crow who refers to her as Emma in his
personal writings was initially training
her to do this with SCP 148 the infamous
telekill alloy however he also filed a
formal request to go further saying I
think it's about time we started trying
to utilize Z4 Z's abilities or at the
very least allowing her to use them
enough to actually learn how to control
them she will not be able to rely on the
SCP 148 hair pieces forever we theorize
that as she gets older her powers will
increase exponentially possibly to the
point where her unconscious telepathy
cannot be contained he also somewhat
infamously went ham with a series of
experiments using SCP 158 a frightening
anomalous device known as the soul
extractor which contrary to its name
Professor Crow also realized could place
remove Souls into other objects or
creatures this led to the creation of a
being that Crow dubbed zero because it
was subject zero in his experiments to
create a composite Soul using SCP 158 he
spoke of this subject somewhat creepily
in his notes zero would make an
excellent candidate for my assistant it
respects and admires me for its creation
much as a child would an endearing
father figure I have assured it that it
would be treated well and that I would
give it a host to the best of my ability
to create all that it asks of me is that
it be given a name other than zero a
name not a number I told it to give
itself a name to Chen itself whatever it
so wishes it told me it would have to
think about it like a lot of strange and
fascinating figures everything you learn
about Professor C pathos Crow seems to
raise new questions is Crow just a mad
scientist Without a Cause eager to
perform bizarre experiments for their
own sake well not quite the sum total of
all of Professor Crow's work is Project
Olympia a topic that probably deserves a
whole video in its own right and do
sound off in the comments if you'd like
to hear more about the deranged
Frankenstein Project that Professor Crow
has devoted his life to you see project
Olympia is Crow's baby and also his
attempt to play God through combining a
variety of different anomalies including
all the ones we've mentioned here and
several others he would hope to create
an entirely artificial living thing that
would serve the interests of the SCP
Foundation how exactly this would be
beneficial to the SCP Foundation is
admittedly a little confusing but seeing
this goal through to its conclusion has
become an all-consuming obsession for
Professor crra he's performed countless
experiments with a huge catalog of
anomalies under the project Olympia
umbrella he's written Rams upon reams of
notes and logs on the subject and
produced a huge number of prototypes
he's also used project Olympia as a
pretense to remove even more Souls using
a SCP 158 because that just appears to
be a strange obsession of his doesn't it
incidentally we aren't the only ones
confused about the exact purpose and
value of project Olympia when members of
the 05 Council finally got a proper look
at Professor Crow's work with the
project they released the following
statement all activity related to
project Olympia has been discontinued
OverWatch command has deemed it to be a
gross waste of resources and permanently
removed support for the project with
Personnel assigned to work with it being
moved to Alternative sites a hearing is
to be held with the project
administrators to determine how the
project was able to continue as long as
it did despite the lack of any concrete
results prototypes and other equipment
have been slated to be decommissioned
Professor Crow took this news about as
well as you could expect but in the end
he always finds a way to wriggle out and
continue doing whatever he wants to do
because that's what Professor C pathos
Crow is all about he's living proof that
sometimes you just can't keep a good dog
down to paraphrase noted scientist Dr
Hines doofen schmerz if I had a nickel
for every time there was a safe class
anomaly that manifests an absurdly long
entity that's stuck on the ground and
pops up at multiple points around the
world and have two nickels which isn't a
lot but it's weird that it's happened
twice incidentally that happens to be
the case with SCP 1193 The Bu Giant and
SCP
2952 Corgi they're a pair of mysterious
creatures with very thought-provoking
similarities between them but while both
are exceedingly long entities neither
are particularly long stories So today
we're giving you a rare SCP explained
anomaly double feature let's begin with
the first of our two very long boys SCP
1193 the exact nature of SCP 1193
anomalous qualities are challenging to
Define it appears to have biolog olical
spatial and even temporal elements SCP
11931 the primary component of SCP 1193
is a human arm that appears completely
normal in a genetic sense but exhibits a
freakish length and bone structure this
absurdly long arm was first discovered
in a drainage pipe inside the basement
of a telephone switching station in
Scottdale Arizona where it had somehow
become trapped how this anomaly was
first discovered or by whom is not
recorded approximately 10 cm below the
drainage gate of the pipe the arm
terminates in what seems to be a human
hand of indeterminate gender that is
unremarkable in both size and structure
upon initial examination the foundation
believed that the arm somehow threaded
through 35 M of drainage pipe but the
use of an endoscopic camera within the
pipe revealed that the reality is much
more severe the arm extends to at least
71 km beneath the Earth which is around
double the overall length of Scottdale
Arizona it's itself with elbows
regularly spaced across every 4 km of
arm elbows below a depth of 26 km are
slightly retroflex to accommodate a 9°
Southward Bend in the drainage bore hole
interestingly the arm was also somehow
able to pass through the morovich
discontinuity which is the lower limit
of the Earth's crust and the volcanic
hot upper mantle the arm could actually
be longer than what we're currently
aware but the foundation doesn't have
any technology Hardy enough to follow
the arm all the way down into the Earth
conversations that Foundation staff have
had with what is believed to be SCP
11931 via the use of SCP
11932 indicates that the entity may have
no Thermo reception it has described
itself as being stuck in environments
that contextually should have either
extremely high or extremely low
temperatures this does not seem to
register with us SCP
11931 this may serve as an explanation
as to why it is experiencing no
discomfort despite the Bold temperatures
having been measured in excess of 674 de
Centigrade but what exactly is SCP
11932 SCP 1193 d02 is a GPO 746 rotary
telephone with a topaz yellow plastic
exterior manufactured in
1971 because of the physical dimensions
of the phone it is too large to have
been delivered from below via the bore
hole so we know that SCP 1193 d01 didn't
put it there the working theory of
foundation researchers assigned to the
1193 case is that the phone was
installed here specifically to
facilitate Communications with the
trapped SCP 1193 d01 it is attached to a
conventional twisted pair line which
enters the drainage pipe containing SCP
1193 d01 and ascends parallel to SCP
1193 d01 until endoscopy is no longer
practical who or what installed the
phone how and to what end Beyond just
chatting with the entity the foundation
doesn't presently know and the
investigation is ongoing one clue to the
purpose of SCP
11932 is the fact that its rotary dial
has been permanently glued in place
rendering it unusable for any kind of
outgoing calls instead the phone only
receives calls and the only calls it
seems to receive are from a being that
seems to be SCP 1193 d01 every weekday
between 8:32 a.m. a.m. and 10:34 p.m.
mountain standard time the phone will
ring up to five times when answered by a
member of foundation Personnel an
unidentified voice believed to be that
of SCP
11931 will willingly engage in
conversation with the person on the
other end of the line the foundation has
used this opportunity to question SCP
11931 about its own nature but it's
impossible to really know how reliable
the entity's answers are the voice on
the line always refers to itself as a
human being and often mistakes the
foundation Personnel for authority
figures such as doctors firemen or
police as a result of this The Voice has
been forthcoming with information and
the interviews have been relatively
straightforward there have been notable
similarities between the information
that the voice voluntarily gives about
itself and the known facts about the
condition of SCP
11931 lending credibility to the idea
that they are one and the same the
foundation fastidiously records
conversations with the voice and as
created a list of anomalous details The
Entity has surrendered during the phone
calls these include having human
features but an anomalous body plan so
the voice seems to have all the right
pieces for a human being but in a
bizarre configuration this may explain
the extremely long many jointed arm
whatever species or subspecies this
entity is it may not be alone as the
voice often refers to a cousin or some
kind of other relative who's on the way
to pick it up the voice often talks
about it its feelings of discomfort or
boredom at its state of being confined
it also makes reference to strange
seismic activity along the little Chino
fault complex an upper branch of the
Elenor fault zone of Southern California
over 300 Mi away from Arizona this may
be because the source of the voice is so
far underground it's still able to feel
the Tremors resonating upwards but one
of the most frequent trends of all in
these conversations is that the voice
venting frustration that its arm or some
other body part is stuck in An
Inconvenient place this list of places
has been exhaustive but includes
handcuffs a jelly jar a pipe a cast or
in one instance a gopher hole naturally
this has been seen as a cause for
concern among Foundation staff if SCP
1193 does have spatially anomalous
components is it possible that someone
could find a 70 km arm sticking out of a
gopher hole or a jelly jar sometime soon
only time will tell the foundation
currently regards any information about
the physical form of the entity beyond
the exposed section of the arm reached
via endoscopy as provisional in other
words they really have no idea what
they're dealing with here and are
unlikely to find out for sure anytime
soon two phone conversations with The
Voice via SCP 1193 d02 have been
transcribed in the addendum to 1193 is
main file both our conversations between
the voice and Doctor Hassan IAL director
of research at the local SCP Containment
site in the first of conversations
recorded on March 24th 2008 Dr ibal
asked who was calling and the voice
identified itself as David The Voice or
David appeared to be in its usual state
of frustration and distress incorrectly
believing that Dr ikbal was a medical
doctor at the hospital he was currently
trapped inside David implored him to
remove the cast from his bottom arm when
Dr ibal questioned David on what exactly
a bottom arm is he responded with
confusion when Dr ikbal told him that he
he was a research scientist not a
medical doctor David became frustrated
implied that Dr ibal was incompetent and
hung up the next recorded call between
Dr ibal and the voice occurred exactly a
year later in this call The Voice
incorrectly believed that Dr ibal was a
fireman The Voice complained about
having reached into its oven to pull out
some cakes becoming stuck in the process
he pleaded for help saying that the oven
was a tight fit when Dr iul showed
concern about the potentially high
temperatures within the oven The Voice
didn't seem to know what he meant in the
end the voice became frustrated and
resolved to instead call its Cousin It
apologized and hung up most calls appear
to follow this General structure because
of the static and Incredibly subdued
nature of the anomaly the foundation has
deemed that SCP 1193 poses no meaningful
risk of containment breach as a result
it has been given the rare safe
classification in order to keep it
properly contained the drainage bore
hole containing SCP 11930 1 is capped
with a Tungsten steel grate containing a
locking 2.5 cm endoscopy aperture
meaning a small hole through which to
feed the endoscopic camera every 48
Hours the drainage bore hole is
inspected with an endoscope for any
further developments concerning the
anomalous arm seismographic monitoring
devices are posted at 2 7 and 11 km
depths alongside the SCP 1193 d01 bore
hole seismic readings consistent with a
Subterranean movement are reported
immediately to site director ikbal in
the event of what is referred to as
Subterranean Containment Breach
researchers and guards working around
1193 are ordered to perform protocol
473a this involves severing SCP 1193
below the fifth elbow and backfilling
remaining portions of the bore hole with
pressurized concrete to seal the hole
forever the SCP 1193 -02 phone is
monitored at all times by a train
Foundation interrogator and standard
procedure dictat atates that SCP 11193
d02 is to be answered on or before the
third ring during these calls the
interrogator will attempt to elicit
valuable information about SCP 1193 from
The Voice and all valuable Intel will
then be recorded and logged the Buri
giant is one of the more perplexing safe
class anomalies handled by the SCP
Foundation so much about its true nature
is unknown to this day but a concern
that both we and the foundation share is
not knowing where the entity's other
limbs are currently resing in for all we
know they could be sticking out of an
oven a go hole or even a jelly jar
somewhere near you weird right well if
you think that's strange let us now
introduce you to SCP
2952 or Corgi trust us if you're not
familiar with this one already you are
not ready for the strange turns this is
about to take in the simplest terms
Corgi is a cheerful Welsh pimber Corgi
with an adorable face and a thick shiny
coat he's also over 30,000 km in length
with his head and front legs sticking
out of the ground in Portland Oregon and
his hindquarters being all the way over
in a rural area of Japan's Kwa District
his body weaves all across the globe
with sections of it surfacing all over
the Americas Europe and much of Asia
studies to find African or Australian
sections of SCP 2952 are still ongoing
despite his massive length there seems
to be no delay in reaction times either
you Pat his head in the USA and his tail
will immediately start wagging over in
Japan he's honestly just precious he
also doesn't appear to need food or
water and thanks to the somewhat
sadistic experiments of one researcher
Mills we know that he can quickly
regenerate from all Damage Done to him
too okay now you're familiar with this
very good albeit very long lad it's time
for things to get really really strange
you see on the different exposed section
of SCP 29 52's body there are tiny
openings designated SCP 2952 D1 stay
with us here there are 324 openings all
over the world some in major cities
others in Suburban areas some in the
tiniest and most rural of hamlets at
this point you probably have the very
reasonable question why are there over
300 openings in this dog well we're
going to answer that but we can't
promise it won't just give you more
confusing questions when the openings
appear humanoid beings designated SCP
29522 will begin to exit the Corgi for
the sake of clarity will refer to these
little creatures as the Welsh Fair folk
or the Fay though there are many
different subgroups of Fay and we really
do mean little in this case on average
they're a puny 3 cm tall and they're
also invisible to the naked eye with
indirect methods like photographs or
videos being the only way to view them
though they do leave evidence of their
presence beyond their direct physical
appearances like Shadows or Footprints
Corgi acts as a kind of transport system
for these little people openings on the
dextrous side of SCP 2952 take
passengers West while those on the
sinistrous side take passengers East
passengers can be seen entering and
exiting at regular intervals the
foundation has even been able to track a
group of passengers getting on the Corgi
transit system and getting off at a
later stop from this the foundation has
been able to estimate that the speed of
the system is 120 km per hour excluding
stops to let passengers on and off along
the way which for the record is a pretty
leisurely Pace by train standards
naturally the SCP Foundation weren't
exactly thrilled to learn about an
anomalous transit system that work to
spread further anomalies all over the
world in fact that's kind of a nightmare
scenario for them so they marshaled
their Global forces located each of the
openings along the Torso of the Corgi
system and block them up at this point
the SCP Foundation were ready to give
themselves a pat on the back close up
shop for the night and go out for
afterwork drinks however there was one
thing that that they'd all forgotten
Hell hath no fury like a society of
Welsh Fay who've just had their daily
commute ruined the Council of tywi teg
their ruling body doesn't take kindly to
having their Public Services messed with
and the manner of their retaliation was
less like a group of disgruntled
anomalous civil servants and more like a
kind of Fay mafia they would make the
foundation Ru the day they messed with
Corgi with a series of retaliatory
strikes that group of Interest like
chaos Insurgency and the children of the
Scarlet King could only dream of it
began with the kidnapping of Project
Director Stevens who'd authorized the
containment project he vanished from his
apartment and was replaced with an adult
European mole which seems to be the Fay
equivalent of leaving a horse's head in
the bed as an offer you can't refuse to
send a message but it didn't stop there
over the next 3 weeks 17 different
members of personnel specifically
construction workers who'd worked on the
project woke up to find that the walls
of their houses had been entirely
replaced by poison ivy and death cap
mushrooms and after 2 months researcher
Mills the weird dog torturer we told you
about earlier woke up with a highly
poisonous nightshade berries in his
mouth and Hawthorne Stakes driven
through his hands and feet crucifixion
style all perpetrated by some very upset
3-in transport workers at this point the
foundation put together who was behind
these attacks and decided to try to make
amends with the Fay whom they'd
understandably upset with their
treatment of Corgi a plan was drafted to
have all the SCP
29521 entrances unburied after this
undertaking was completed the Fay
retribution came to an end and most of
the damage was undone director Stevens
was returned unharmed the construction
workers got their walls back and well
researcher Mills didn't get better but I
think we can all agree that animal
cruelty isn't really a crime that we
should be forgiving lightly after all
this chaos had transpired and the SCP
Foundation had fully made amends
director Stevens had a note left on his
desk by a starling which then flew off
before it could be caught by the way can
we just take a second to appreciate that
the SCP Foundation has contained literal
demigods and interdimensional Horrors
but director Stevens was out foxed by a
bird wonderful those Fay truly are built
different anyway the note on his desk
translated from Welsh R thank you for
your prompt response to commuter
complaints and wonderful customer
service as such we have granted all
members of your organization
complimentary Transportation on our cour
system please send a sparrow to the
Council of the C office nearest you if
you have further questions G flock glove
director of Transportation the Council
of the tiwi tag and with tremendous
relief that the Slate had finally been
cleared the foundation decided that they
would accept the kind offer extended to
them by the council and send one of
their field agents to take a look inside
the Corgi system the field agent in
question was agent Elizabeth Davies
chosen for her Pleasant social skill and
Proficiency in Welsh with the intention
to take a ride in mind and connected to
an audio and video feeds linked back to
Central Command agent Davies touched the
site of Corgi this caused her to shrink
down to a height of 3.2 CM much like all
the other commuters she stepped into the
SCP 2952 entrance and found that on the
inside it looked not unlike a regular
train though some carriages seemed to be
in disrepair and everything was written
in Welsh oh and everything was made with
wood and plant matter too the chassis
appeared to be constructed from Birch
and all the seat cushions were made of
flower pedals it was all very Whimsical
honestly agent Davies struck up
conversations with some of the other
commuters one complained about delays
caused by the fact that Corgi was
suffering from kidney stones a problem
that the foundation is eager to help the
poor animal get over to keep the transit
system running smoothly she also chatted
with a sweet elderly lady on the train
who was getting people to sign a
petition to allow mice back onto the
Corgi transit system when agent Davies
Departed the system she patted the dog
and told him he was a good boy before
returning to normal size since January
5th 2017 the Corgi system and its
passengers have become invisible to
everyone who wasn't officially under SCP
Foundation employ this has allowed it
for its reclassification as a safe
anomaly so there you have it Folks at
least one of our two very long boys got
everything sorted out we love
occasionally doing a happy ending here
at SCP explained remember to stay tuned
for our next episode about the time that
SCP 106 managed to get onto a school bus
what we did say occasionally Josie is a
half cat no she isn't half cat half
something else and she's not a humanoid
with feline features either she is
literally half of a cat actually to be
more precise she is the front half but
an otherwise ordinary black and gray
tabby cat that is ordinary apart from
having no visible back legs or hind
quarters you might think that'd make it
hard for Josie to get get around but if
you asked her on how only being a half
cat affects her on a daily basis well
she wouldn't be able to answer you due
to the simple fact that cats generally
can't speak but nevertheless Josie will
happily and effortlessly walk around on
her own two legs moving as if she had a
second pair of hind legs in place behind
her her back half isn't invisible it's
as if it's not even there at all not
showing up on X-rays and yet it can give
a slight yield when touched being almost
tangible but not fully despite this
Josie suffers no adverse health problems
or any other complications despite
lacking one half of her body
occasionally she doesn't mind having her
semic corporeal hind quarter stroked
although she will usually get a little
bit scratchy if people try that so how
does the SCP Foundation keep an anomaly
like Josie contained well it turns out
that they don't really need to she's
perfectly harmless and is actually
allowed to roam freely around the lower
levels of the facility she's kept at
casually as you like she slinks around
the corridors passing from one room to
the next of course if cats could talk
then Josie would probably tell you that
she has the run of the whole facility
the only real question left is what does
a half cat do when she's left to wander
around a foundation facility completely
unsupervised easy she starts looking for
a ball of yarn Josie was sure she'd seen
one somewhere around here one of the
researchers had carried it off for
testing not too long ago her small front
paws patted against the ground as Josie
navigated her way to where she last
remembered seeing that coveted ball of
yarn being taken she passed a group of
researchers one of them kneeling down to
give her a friendly scratch behind the
ears just as she closed her eyes and
purred at the greeting a sound coming
from down the hall startled her it was a
low distressed sobbing having never been
taught that old s saying about curiosity
and cats Josie slunk past the
researcher's legs towards the source of
the noise the room that the crying was
coming from had no windows no way for
her to get in luckily Josie despite only
having half a body had enough
determination and resourcefulness for
two whole cats around the corner she
knew there was an open air vent and sure
enough she leaped gracefully up to it
with ease the cold metal tunnel was just
big enough to accommodate her little
furry self as she crawled through the
echoing sound of sobs guiding her as she
reached the great looking out into the
windowless room Josie spotted a tall
thin creature sitting with its back to
her its arms would have been long enough
to reach the ground if it had stood at
its full height but for now they were
wrapped tightly around its legs as the
creature rocked back and forth its loud
whales showed that it was clearly in a
great deal of distress although Josie
wouldn't be able to understand why
having someone look at its face would
make this slender creature so upset
nearby there was a giant metal cube with
a hole ripped in it and while the rest
of the room was empty there seemed to be
several large red smears on the ground
how strange she cocked her head to one
side and meowed tapping one paw against
the air vent grate it seemed pretty
loose with a few good pushes the screws
came free and the adorable half cat
hopped down into the room as she got
closer to the creature she noticed it
had a black bag covering its face little
did Josie know an hour earlier a junior
researcher had made the terrible mistake
of putting on a pair of X-ray glasses he
ordered from the back of a comic book as
it turns out these were the only ones to
ever actually work he saw right through
096 his containment Cube and all hell
had broken loose but Josie didn't mind
she decided to endear herself to the
strange shy creature by rubbing up
against its long leg returning the same
affection that it had so rarely been
given it bent down down and gently
scooped Josie up in its spinley arms the
pair of them sat in the corner together
Josie getting herself comfortable on the
tall creatur's lap purring as long
fingers ran over her Tabby fur the
creature being so careful not to harm
the half cat treated her like she was as
delicate as glass it had briefly stopped
crying thanks to its visitor and as much
as she noticed the sounds of sobbing had
ceased Josie would never understand the
difference she had made to scp096 his
day unfortunately it wasn't long before
their encounter was cut short a legion
of guards in scramble goggles burst into
the room to retake control of the
situation the last thing they expected
to see was 096 sitting calmly with Josie
on its lap and a bag covering its face
but the sudden entrance of a security
team startled the poor half cat within a
second she had bolted out of the room
shooting under the legs of the guards
and back out into the facility now that
she was back outside Josie recalled her
earlier hunt for a ball of yarn to play
with she still wasn't sure where it had
gotten to maybe someone had moved it
pacing over to the elevator she stared
up at the heavy steel doors the numbers
above were gradually ticking down
denoting Which floor the elevator had
currently stopped at of course Josie
couldn't read so instead she sat and
meowed loudly at the elevator maybe if
she made enough noise the doors would
eventually open eventually after a few
short minutes of waiting and growling
the door slid apart another gaggle of
researchers passed her by and Josie
plotted into the elevator spotting a
familiar face one of the researchers a
Doctor by the name of Sophie cartright
was still inside and smiled down at the
half-cat Explorer Dr cartrite had come
across Josie a few times enough for the
Intrepid little tabby to consider them
friends where to Josie Dr cartright
asked her hand hovering over the
elevator's buttons as if in reply Josie
looked up and meowed humans always
seemed to smile if she meowed after
they'd said something to her so sophy
chuckled and pushed the door close
button hold the elevator another much
grelier voice called a hand or rather a
paw reached out and caught the doors
before they could slide closed it was
another of the foundation's doctors one
with both a considerable reputation and
a very distinguishing look to say the
least Dr Cain pathos Crow stepped inside
the elevator and pushed one of the
buttons Sophie had to force herself to
keep her head down but couldn't help
herself from stealing the occasional
glance up at Dr Crow she heard the
rumors about A peculiar anomalous event
changing his appearance but had never
seen him up close before Josie on the
other hand couldn't take her eyes off
Crow staring up at him froze to the spot
and letting out a low cautious whne if
her tail was visible Sophie would have
seen it swaying from side to side as The
Brave Little half-cat kept her defensive
ground standing between her friend Dr
cartright and her mortal enemy you see
Dr Crow was a dog or or at least a man
who had been turned into something very
much like a dog still capable of speech
but with a distinctively canine body
Crow kept to himself the entire ride
down although Sophie could feel the
tension between the dog body doctor and
her little half-cat friend out of the
corner of his eye Dr Crow spotted Josie
trying his best to ignore her he let out
a low discomforted growl the kind of dog
makes when they're on edge to his credit
he couldn't really help it the man had
been turned into a can after all but it
took all his stoicism to suppress a bark
and to stop himself from chasing Josie
around the cramped elevator arriving at
her floor Sophie stepped down followed
by little Josie who Moved as far away
from Crow as quickly as she could the
doors closed once more and sent him
further down into the depths of the
facility as she turned to look Sophie
noticed Josie had craned her head up to
check on her a were you protecting me
Josie she asked with a smile bending
down to thank the half cat with a
scratch behind the ears before she could
stay for too long Josie and her human
companion parted each heading down
separate winding corridors there was a
funny smell hanging in the air like
something gradually melting and bubbling
only to reform and melt again filling
the half cat's pink nose with a strange
burning scent as she passed a holding
cell something broke Josie's
concentration yet again the noise of a
hand tapping at glass she turned and
instantly meowed a greeting to the
second familiar face of the day albeit a
more beaked face face kneeling down on
the other side of the glass the black
robed plague doctor waved politely at
the Dual pod passer by sitting in front
of the glass hoping to be let in Josie
gave another meow I quite well the
doctor mused and how are you my dear he
asked politely Josie got up on her back
legs or rather that's what it would have
looked like if she had hind quarters
instead it looked like she was almost
floating in place from halfway down
stretching her front paws up reaching
towards the birdlike face face as the
mask Doctor playfully tapped his fingers
against the glass to amuse his feline
friend no I cannot let you in I'm afraid
he sighed sounding a touch more
melancholic not that a half cat can
understand the difference in someone's
Cadence not all of us here are gifted
the freedom you enjoy my furry friend
freedom is not something this
organization would ever understand no
matter how much they claim to know us
the fact of the matter is they never
really listen from the other side of the
glass last Josie blinked and cocked her
head to one side confused she'd barely
heard a word he said oh but listen to me
go on the plague doctor chuckled
wrapping his fingers in front of the
half cat again I suppose you'll be
looking for that ball of yarn they took
for testing I saw them carrying the box
it was in that way he pointed and josy's
little green cat eyes followed the
direction of his finger barely able to
comprehend what had been said to her she
simply meowed up in thanks and plotted
the way she'd been directed fwell little
Josie as CP 049 said quietly from inside
its cell watching the half cat until she
had disappeared from view as she
continued through the lower levels of
the facility Josie slipped through doors
seconds before they closed leapt up onto
tables and dashed between legs that
strange smell was back having caught her
attention and distracted her from her
Quest again tracking it to its source
Josie suddenly felt uneasy she entered a
room with a huge vat of acid the source
of the burning scent she' picked up on
though it was what was inside the V
trapped in a loop of regenerating itself
only to be melted over and over again by
the acid that got her feeling defensive
the vast reptilian monstrosity sensed a
small life form outside its tank and
opened one yellow eye squinting through
the Searing burning acid at the tiny
little creature staring up at it the
reptile snarled screwing its now healed
eyes shut and swiping what was left of
its limbs at the glass rearing back
Josie gave the monster her fiercest hiss
bearing her fangs at it the Beast
usually abhor other beings finding all
other forms of life unnatural
unforgivable and so detestable that it
would normally stop at nothing to
eradicate them but today a tiny tabby
cat with her entire back half missing
was standing up to the crocodilian
Nightmare and it barely had enough will
to retaliate maybe it was just too
lethargic too tired to try anything
today perhaps it didn't think she was
worth the effort or figured it would see
to her along with the researchers and
guards next time it broke free from
containment and went on yet another
Killing Spree but in Josie's mind this
facility was her home and The Brave
Little half-cat had scared SCP 682 into
staying put as she Trot it away again
she knew that the Monstrous reptile
would have to think twice before messing
with her back on track at last Josie
rounded the corner and arrived in a
familiar looking Corridor she was
certain this was where she'd seen a
researcher carrying the box containing
the string that she coveted sure enough
she could see into the room where the
Box had been left noticing a group of
researchers and a human in an orange
jumpsuit were gathered around it a few
were making notes on their clipboards at
a safe distance while the one in Orange
stepped closer to the Box Josie watched
as a single bee flew out of the box her
feline eyes followed it ready to pounce
if it came close enough the man wearing
the jumpsuit was waving his arms trying
to swat the insect away a moment later
he grabbed his arm in pain the bee had
gotten agitated stinging him and flying
away somehow surviving as she waited
Josie's patience was rewarded the
researchers and the man wearing orange
bustled their way out of the room
offering her the chance she needed to
zip between them and get one step closer
to her prize the room was entirely empty
safe for the box in the center sitting
precariously at top a table wiggling
herself as she readied her invisible and
intangible back legs Josie shot up just
missing the table's Edge she clawed and
scratched at the surface trying to pull
herself up but her lack of hind quarters
made it impossible to climb the rest of
the way dropping back to the floor she
looked up at the table and gave it a
loud indignant meow changing tactics she
started to hop up on one of the table
legs digging her claws into the woodwork
to hoist herself up bit by bit sure
enough her new strategy worked a treat
and Josie was presented with what she
had been searching for one final hurdle
was left however the box was closed now
the struggles of only being a half cat
are one thing but not having opposable
thumbs is a difficulty that has plagued
all cats since the dawn of time but not
being able to grab or hold things with
the ease of a human there's one thing
that cats are great at and that's
pushing things over nudging the box to
the table's edge with a gentle Boop of
her nose Josie eventually tipped the
whole thing off causing it to land on
its side on the floor the lid falling
open triumphantly she jumped back down
to CL claimer prize expecting to find
the ball of yarn and spend the next few
hours playing with it but something was
wrong the yarn had changed and now was
looking at her the ball had started as
yarn and ribbon the perfect play thing
for any half cat or full cat for that
matter but the foundation had been
running their usual invasive tests on it
and since cutting a portion of the
string off it had transformed it was now
a ball of meat functioning blinking eyes
staring out of a mass of overlapping
sine and blood red m matter the multiple
eyes looked up at the half cat that had
knocked it to the floor and asked a
single question in a deep voice
emanating from somewhere within its
lipless form are you Eric completely
unfazed by this Josie whacked the ball
with her paw and watched as it rolled
halfway across the room tentacle
segments of its body gradually pulled
the amorphous Mass back to where it
started and then asked once again are
you Eric once again Josie slapped the
ball and watched it rolled away from her
both completely unaware of who Eric was
and a little perturbed that someone had
replaced the ball of yarn with such an
inadequate toy turning her back on SCP
066 Josie the half cat searched for a
way out of the room and went back to
prowling around the facility for
something to entertain herself she
noticed that she was starting to get
hungry maybe if she got lucky one of the
researchers would sneak her a piece of
cheese what's the largest animal you can
think of okay that's probably too vague
of a question your mind probably went
straight to the oceans picturing deep
sea leviathans like the mighty blue
whale let's go a little bit closer shall
we what about on land what are the
biggest animals that live up here with
us above the water elephants maybe what
about rhinos then again hippos are up
there too in the same kind of ballpark
all pretty huge what about cows they can
grow pretty big right especially with
all the crazy growth hormones that meat
manufacturers pump into them these days
well what if there was something out
there bigger than all of those imagine
it some huge Beast roaming the
Wilderness that easily towered above any
creature you've ever seen in your life
this thing would be massive striding
across the world towering above the
meager height of a human being now
imagine that this thing whatever it was
wasn't just big but kept getting bigger
sure all of this might sound like the
premise for the next Godzilla or
Cloverfield movie but while big Charlie
might not be the king of the monsters it
certainly lives up to that first part of
its nickname of course the SCP
Foundation calls it SCP 4158 big Charlie
is just the playful nickname that the
owners gave it although none of them are
sure who was the first to call the
creature by that name standing on four
long legs at 3.4 M tall when the
foundation first discovered it SCP 4158
was about 1 and 35ths times as tall as
famous professional basketball player
Shaquille O'Neal but since then well
like we said big Charlie is getting
bigger day by day the creature appears
to be tangentially related to the Bine
family of mammals essentially making it
a ginormous cow however SCP 4158 lacks
the facial structure and features that
you might expect to see on the faces at
your local Farm the creature has thin
translucent skin which is so fragile
that it often tears easily and anyone
observing SCP 4158 can often see the
bones and internal organs within gross
it possesses a large bulbous head with a
protrusion at the front almost like a
beak as well as that its huge eyes are
foggy a milky white color which seems to
suggest that SCP 4158 is at least
partially blind the large Catal like
mammal is incredibly skinny almost to
the point where its bones stick out from
underneath its skin its legs are longer
than the rest of its colossal body and
seem barely able to support the animal's
weight on description alone you can't
help but feel sorry for the poor
creature and its sorry state of living
normally big Charlie is mostly Cal and
docile barely acknowledging the
foundation Personnel that come to
examine it feed it or clean its
containment cell held in a heavy
containment Zone SCP 4158 is fed through
a 5 m trough on the far East wall of its
cell surviving on a diet of raw beef hay
wood and Bricks not the typical grasson
eating habits you'd expect from normal
cows but according to the foundation's
extensive testing on the creature its
diet doesn't seem to be what is causing
SCP 4158 to keep growing at the rate it
has been the mass of big Charlie is in
some sort of state of Perpetual increase
meaning its size and weight are always
growing and it is because of this
continuous growth that every week the
foundation is forced to Shear off great
swaths of excess meat from from the
creature cleaving off its flesh and
incinerating the mass all while big
Charlie is still alive now before you
start dialing peta's hotline it's also
worth mentioning big Charlie can't feel
pain what's more testing has revealed
that the meat taken from SCP 4158 is
USDA utility grade beef the kind that
would normally come from older cattle
utility grade meat has no fat marbling
so it isn't as tender or as flavorsome
as other more premium grades but would
normally be used in canned and processed
food products and despite the foundation
destroying the excess that they cut off
of big Charlie as a precaution in theory
the meat is still good to eat and
possesses no anomalous properties then
again would you really want to eat a
burger made from SCP 4158 I didn't think
so if left unchecked and allowed to grow
for longer than a week SCP 4158 will
begin to form new features limbs organs
and sometimes even G genal will Sprout
from random places all over its body the
previous record for Big Charlie's most
substantial growth was when he increased
to 8 and 1/2 M tall that's over 3 fths
the height of the Hollywood sign and
over 1 and 1/2 times the average height
of a giraffe at this immense size
Charlie has developed seven legs four
stomachs three tongues and numerous
other extremities before the SCP
Foundation cut him back down to size and
we mean they literally cut him back down
so what exactly is this thing it's like
a giant cow but not actually a cow even
though its flesh is identical to beef
and it's not a destructive rampaging
monster either showing no hostility
towards humans even when they are
shearing its excessive body mass away
could it be some kind of failed genetic
experiment an attempt to solve hunger by
engineering a creature that could not
only stay alive but keep growing after
having its meat cut away if that were
true it would make SCP 4158 a literal
Cash Cow for the meat industry well
we've got kind of a funny story about
that actually big Charlie was first
encountered by the foundation back in
December 2004 in cruden Indiana a number
of calls have been made to the area's
local animal control services with
reports of a large cow with mange
roaming the nearby Highway 17 two
officers belonging to the animal Control
Department were sent out to investigate
these reports and what they found was
SCP 4158 wandering aimlessly but unlike
any cow they had ever seen the officers
called local police where a foundation
plant caught wind of what they had found
and called in containment Specialists
the case was closed after the Animal
Control Officers were given amnestics
and a cover story was put in place about
a cow with mange that was put down where
it had been found in reality the SCP
Foundation rounded up old big Charlie
and transported it to safety with Little
Resistance from the animal they were
able to trace the creature's origin back
to somewhere called butcher block a
nearby slaughterhouse the manager of the
establishment one Jeff fine and a single
employee named Barney Mossman were
brought in by the foundation for
questioning another employee Rory Gilson
was also retrieved from his home after
having called in sick to work that day
Barney Mossman the first of the Butcher
Block employees to be interviewed stated
that SCP 4158 had been called Big
Charlie since long before he had started
his job at the slaughterhouse according
to his testimony he knew nothing about
where the creature had actually come
from only that it was fed hay but would
also occasionally eat anything else it
could including other cows since joining
Butcher Block 4 years earlier Mossman
had been told not to ask questions or to
tell anyone else about SCP 4158 the
morning after the huge creature had
seemingly escaped Mr fine had apparently
angrily accused both Barney and Rory of
selling him out and giving big Charlie
away to the competitors of butcher block
even though they were the only
slaughterhouse in the area but Mossman
was convinced that neither of them were
capable of doing something like that
Rory apparently treated big Charlie like
his own child and fine had an even
stranger relationship with the creature
Rory Gilson the other of Fine's
employees was more helpful in shedding
light on SCP 4158 origin than Barney had
been Rory explained that he and Jeff
fine had bought a pregnant cow from an
unknown person 9 years earlier
considering it to be a steel a two for
the price of one bargain however one day
without warning the calf fell out of its
mother it wasn't born like any ordinary
cow however according to gildon it had
ripped through the mother cow's chest
and looked disgusting while Rory and
Jeff had initially thought the calf to
be dead they discovered it had tried to
get back into the barn after they hauled
it outside their original intention had
been to sell the creature off for
scientific study or failing that to a
freak Show however after their attempts
to sell the calf failed Jeff and Rory
had decided the best course of action
would be to put the animal down they had
reasoned that releasing it into the wild
could have negatively affected the
ecosystem so instead they took a bolt
pistol and pushed it between the
creature's eyes then fired but nothing
happened Rory tried again but ended up
breaking the gun instead they slit the
animal's throat but it barely bled even
butchering it on the Spot while it was
still alive did nothing finding gildon
reduced the calf to little more than a
skeleton but it simply refused to Die
the pair of them packaged the meat they
had removed with the rest hoping no one
would notice or ask where it had come
from it was a few days later that Rory
realized SCP 4158 was capable of
regrowing whatever was cut off of it he
and his boss even tried some and
couldn't tell the difference they had
their hands on a cow that would eat
anything put in front of it and that
could produce infinite meat the
foundation probed Rory gilds in further
for more information on the creature
learning that SCP 4158 was sterile and
in case capable of reproducing the only
one of its kind Rory argued that the
foundation legally couldn't take big
Charlie away that the creature was still
private property little did he realize
he was wrong but he just like Barney
Mossman also knew nothing about how the
animal had escaped in the first place
finally Jeff fine the owner of the
Butcher Block slaughterous was
questioned by the foundation he repeated
Rory's earlier story about the strange
calf that had been born and how it could
regenerate the flesh that was sheared
off of it fine remarked that he
considered it to be a blessing when
asked about his whereabouts on the night
SCP 4158 had escaped from Butcher's
Block Jeff admitted that he had been
praying but not to God to Big Charlie he
had apparently been doing this every
night since realizing what the creature
could do viewing the animal as a
provider and a savior I just felt
something when I was around him I could
tell that he wanted to make this
sacrifice for us ever since he tried to
get into the barn after we threw him him
out I knew he cared for us fine told the
foundation I would open his pen take off
my clothes so that I was pure before him
lay down and receive His blessings and
how would he receive those Blessings by
drinking the animal's blood yeah Jeff
fine was a real excentric like that one
night when fine had entered the pen to
perform this weird ritual big Charlie
had escaped but his owner was convinced
that there must have been a reason for
this that the animal had some sort of
goal when the foundation sta conducting
fins interview dismissed this idea The
Slaughterhouse owner became enraged how
dare you question big Charlie he knows
what's best for all of us I'm done here
I don't need to keep answering questions
like this let me out I need to see big
Charlie I need to see if he's safe the
foundation believes that Jeff Fine's
practice of worshiping SCP 4158 was not
due to any anomalous effect caused by
the creature itself none of the
foundation Personnel tested with feeding
studying and shearing meat off of big
Charlie have displayed any similar
behavior of Performing abnormal
religious rituals he really was just a
huge weirdo as for the Butcher Block
slaughterhouse fine and the rest of his
employees were given him KN scks to
forget big Charlie had ever even existed
and the slaughterhouse was closed under
the false pretense of a health code
violation and its staff being arrested
for malpractice the one question that
remains unanswered however is the
identity of the individ ual that first
sold Jeff find the cow that gave birth
to SCP
4158 it just goes to show you though
sometimes you don't know where your food
is coming from if you lived in Indiana
in late 2004 who knows you might have
eaten some of big Charlie and not even
realized it in an old house an old woman
gathers her knitting supplies this is a
special project for a little boy named
Tommy she loves loves dearly she knits
furiously and soon the mix of cotton
synthetic fiber and cloth of every color
turn from raw materials into something
else a teddy bear she puts the finishing
touches on the bear this is a very
special bear after all and sends the
patchwork bear off to its destination
with a red get well card the card is
labeled Kos the bear and inside she
writes a personal note to Tommy because
only time can mend all wounds love
Grammy but this package of Love would
never reach its destination SCP 2295 was
found at the site of a crashed mail
truck and it looks exactly like a
standard handmade teddy bear with one
difference on the left side of its chest
just under its jaunty tan bow it wears a
heart-shaped pin but not a standard
cartoon heart this is a disturbingly
realistic anatomically correct pin of a
heart organ and that's because SCP 22 95
has a specific purpose and it's one that
has everything to do with actual human
organs SCP 2295 spends most of its time
completely inert spending its days as
just another cuddly stuffed toy tests
performed on the toy revealed that it
had no unusual properties and seems to
be a normal handmade Keepsake that is
until someone is injured in its presence
not any injury will do a paper cut or
even a broken arm for example won't do
much to activate its anomalous
properties but if it detects a critical
injury to a human organ nearby it will
trigger a secret power one that the
foundation is still trying to figure out
how it works because SCP
2295 is a miracle worker when it senses
the presence of someone with a serious
injury to an organ and is within 2 m of
them SCP 2295 Springs into action
suddenly from unknown sources the bear
will produce objects including scissors
white thread in sewing needles or a
crocheting hook from its mouth if there
are any crafting supplies on hand it
will incorporate those as well and then
it gets to work despite only having
hands made of fabric and stuffing with
no fingers the anomalous Bearer is still
able to craft what will end up being a
patchwork Recreation of the damaged
human's organ cute if a little creepy
but that's just the beginning the
injured person mysteriously Falls
unconscious and the patchwork organ
which the foundation has designated as
SCP 22951 instance will disappear the
SCP 22 95-1 instance will then
physically replace the damaged organ
inside the person's body it's unknown
how this happens the patchwork organ
will simply appear inside of their body
taking the place of the original lung or
kidney or whichever organ was failing
it's unknown where the original organ
goes to since it seems to just disappear
as soon as the
22951 instance takes its place
surprisingly having this new cotton
stuffed heart or liver does not seem to
cause any harm and in fact it works
exactly like the real thing there are
never any of the usual issues that come
with a transplant like the risk of it
being rejected by the body as the
organic tissue seems to have no issue
connecting with the organ and treating
it like it was there all along in all
instances of SCP 2295 performing this
adorable but rudimentary surgery the
subjects have made a full and complete
recovery as p2295 might sound like a
miracle worker but that isn't to say
that its abilities aren't without their
own set of complications when faced with
two injured subjects SCP 2295 seems to
always gravitate towards fixing the
younger subject up first maybe owing to
its creation by a grandmother who wanted
to heal whatever was ailing her grandson
no one knows who Tommy was or exactly
what disease or injury he was recovering
from but his grandmother clearly felt it
was serious enough to create this
special be for him while SCP 2295 will
heal anyone it seems to be primarily a
guardian for the young and it takes its
duties very seriously even to the point
of self-sacrifice while SCP 2295 is able
to pull some of its supplies out of thin
air it still always needs some raw
materials to craft the new organ
including Fabric and stuffing and if
there are none available SC SCP 2295
will obtain them the hard way the
patchwork bear will sacrifice its own
body tearing itself open and removing
any Fabric or stuffing it needs without
any concern for its own well-being in
order to craft a new organ for its
patient it slowly regenerates its own
stuffing at the rate of around a gram of
stuffing per day but it needs to harvest
fabric to repair its outer layer which
the foundation happily makes available
to it offering it a variety of patterns
and types it's no surprise that a teddy
bear capable of healing mortal wounds
would be of great interest to the SCP
Foundation and as soon as it was
recovered from the crash mail truck they
immediately began tests to find out more
about it could it heal literally any
organ were there any limits to its
abilities there was only one way to find
out and the foundation had the perfect
test subjects d-class Personnel whose
interactions with non- cuddly teddy bear
SC scps frequently left them with
critical external and internal injuries
the first first test subject brought in
D 2353 a 38-year-old man who was in poor
health not due to his work as a d-class
Personnel but from his years and years
of heavy smoking his lungs were
seriously damaged which gave him trouble
breathing and made any serious physical
exertion extremely difficult he wasn't
critically injured or in danger of dying
immediately but that didn't matter to
SCP
2295 D 2353 quickly passed out and the
Bear sprang into action he proceeded to
take two textile swatches one black and
one red and create a pair of fabric
lungs which had installed in the patient
when he awoke d235 I found he had full
healthy lung function again as if he
never picked up his deadly habit but now
the foundation researchers needed to
know how SCP 2295 would do with even
more complicated ailments
d354 was 50 years old and his heart was
not not in good shape not only did he
have a serious case of
atherosclerosis which is a disease where
cholesterol plaque builds up and blocks
blood flow and can put you at serious
risk of a heart attack but he also had
an irregular heartbeat this d-class was
in bad shape but that was no problem for
SCP 2295 who took a collection of
different colors of yarn in a crochet
hook and created a plushy heart just
like the lungs had acted as if they were
completely regular organs after the
heart and anomalously ended up inside
the man's chest it began to beat
normally and performed all the
complicated functions of a human heart
but there was one detail that shocked
the onlooking doctors before the yarn
organ had vanished the doctors had seen
that it was beating so is there any
organ that SCP 2295 can't replace that
was about to be tested when d78 94 was
brought in a 24-year-old woman she had
suffered serious Burns all over her
torso left abdomen and right leg she was
brought in and sedated to numb the
agonizing pain and researchers were
worried that they had come up against
the limit of SCP 2295 abilities since
the skin is the largest organ after all
but SCP 2295 wasn't phased at all the
bear immediately started sewing segments
of Patchwork Fabric and layering them
onto the damaged skin replacing the
dermis and epidermis layer by layer
unlike the other cases these replac
organs are visible and
d789 now has Patchwork skin just like
her talented surgeon and amazingly the
fabric has the same sense of touch that
her regular skin did the final test of
SCP 2295 abilities came with d
2723 who was only 18 years old this last
minute d-class test was performed
because he was showing signs of severe
cerebral hemorrhage the kind that would
cause brain damage in only minutes would
be followed soon after by complete brain
death SCP 2295 sprung to life but as
soon as it examined the test subject it
became distressed it started frantically
grasping at random material around it as
if it didn't know what to do with them
then it reached inside itself and
provided a large chocolate bar which had
offered to the subject sadly to no
effect it then seemed to admit defeat as
it grabbed tightly onto the subject's
leg observers reported that it was
leaking a tear-like ution from its small
knitted eyes as it embraced the dying
declass in his final moments sadly it
seems that the human brain is the one
mystery that even SCP 2295 can't solve
SCP 2295 appears to pose no threat to
anyone and was classified as safe after
testing it is inactive when not in the
presence of an injured person and has
never displayed hostile instincts when
active the foundation determined that it
should be stored in a standard
containment lock ER in site 37 where it
can be kept safely until it's needed for
tests or to repair an injured SCP
Personnel access is limited to those
with level three or higher security
clearance and any contact with the bear
is highly regulated but there is one
element of SCP 2295 existence that
continues to worry Foundation staff SCP
2295 full Origins and the grandmother
who crafted it are unknown the note it
was found with is the only clue as to
where it may have come from but there
are plenty within the foundation who are
suspicious of the veracity of this
letter and they have good reason not to
be too trusting because another bear
with similar abilities exists and it is
distinctly less benevolent than SCP
2295 SCP 1048 is also a teddy bear but
it is capable of moving on its own and
communicating through gestures at all
times it was initially allowed to wander
around independently and seemed to make
its home at site 24 a happier place but
then it began to display its own
crafting abilities as CP 1048 is able to
craft duplicates of itself and while the
original was seemingly harmless the ones
it made were not these similarly shaped
bears were made of disturbing materials
and were extremely hostile towards any
humans they encountered the first SCP
1048-a was made entirely out of human
ears and when when it shrieked it caused
anyone nearby to generate ear-like
growths all over their bodies eventually
causing them to suffocate the creature
disappeared and an on-site researcher
was found to be missing an ear the
creations of SCP 1048 only got stranger
and deadlier from there SCP 1048-b was
found in the SES cafeteria where it was
moving around in a halted jerky fashion
it then started bursting at the seams
and revealed what appeared to be a human
fetus in died when the creature screamed
it sounded like a much louder version of
a human infant and its crows caused
Massive Internal damage to anyone around
it SCP 1048-b was killed in the ensuing
conflict with Foundation agents ending
its threat but SCP 1048 was learning
deadlier techniques when SCP 1048 C was
discovered it looked to be a teddy bear
made entirely out of Rusty scrap metal
when it was spotted by Dr Carver and
targeted by found Foundation Personnel
the creature turned violent and proved
to have Incredible strength jumping
through the agents who were trying to
neutralize it tearing through their
bodies like tissue paper attempts to
damage it were unsuccessful and both it
and the bear made out of ears are still
on the loose along with the original SCP
1048 capturing it is Major priority for
the foundation because no one wants to
see what it will create next is there a
connection between these two very
different teddy bears no one has been
able to answer this question the origins
of SCP 1048 are unknown and so is any
connection to the mysterious grandmother
who may have made Kos the bear but their
abilities are similar with both able to
craft living objects out of seemingly
any material they just have very
different ideas as to what a good use of
their crafting abilities are it is
fortunate that an anomaly as potentially
powerful as SCP 2295 seems to only want
one thing to help those in need
especially those who are the most
vulnerable obviously it helps to be an
animal lover when you start working at a
shelter it's not exactly a requirement
of the job but it definitely makes it a
little more palatable when you
occasionally have to deal with a critter
that's more nasty than usual having an
already built-in compassion towards
animals makes it easier to forgive them
for not doing what you want from a very
young age har always liked to think of
animals as people they just didn't think
or communicate the same way as humans
even the best trained pets in the world
don't really know the actual meaning of
certain words they're just taught how to
respond to specific commands in certain
ways but that doesn't mean they couldn't
also have distinct personalities of
their own just like humans do and then
of course there were all the wild
animals that had never been trained or
domesticated Harper always felt a little
sorry for any baby bird with its wing
broken or any badgers or posum that
arrived at the shelter after getting hit
by a car they didn't live around humans
and had probably never even experienced
being indoors before let alone having
people nursing them back to health to
empathize Harper used to imagine how
terrified she would be if she was hurt
if she'd broken her leg or arm or Worse
only for something much larger than her
to take her into a structure she'd never
been in before and on top top of that
having no way of understanding that this
giant was trying to help her heal as
well as being separated from her friends
family and everyone she knew the way she
saw it this was what it must have been
like for the majority of animals that
were brought into the shelter where she
worked and she wanted to do her best to
help calm her little furry or feathered
patience you got a fortify your heart in
this job harp her friends who worked
with her at the shelter would say and it
was true to an extent they didn't mean
she'd have to become cold and heartless
that would be an overcorrection but it
was their and Harper's responsibility to
administer the appropriate Medical Care
and provide a temporary Sanctuary to
these lost wounded or abandoned animals
what Harper had to remember was that
none of them were her own pets often a
lot of the critters that were brought
into the shelter were already someone
else's companion and might have just got
lost while out on a walk and while some
others were given up by their previous
owners who had cruy Shrugged off the
responsibility of caring for them those
animals were in need of new homes and
couldn't stay cooped up in the shelter
forever not everyone that gave up their
pet did it callously though sometimes
they might have found themselves falling
on hard times and being unable to
financially look after an animal others
might have owned a pet that had a
behavioral problem like being too
aggressive and even though the person
still loved them dearly they might have
just not been able to make it could work
in times like that they'd have no choice
but to take their animal to the shelter
just outside the side entrance was an
area where people could drop off their
animals and quickly Buzz to the staff
inside just in case they wanted to avoid
a protracted emotional farewell to their
four-legged or winged companion the
buzzer had sounded just as Harper had
been coming off for lunch break it was
her turn this shift to quickly go and
collect any animal that had been left
out there even though their owners
usually left them in their cave cage or
with their lead tied to a nearby Street
Lamp Harper knew she had to rush to the
side door just in case somebody else
tried to rush in and steal the poor
abandoned pet after turning them in the
lock she hooked her keys back on the
belt clip she wore and pushed the side
door open Harper had been fully
expecting to see the usual a leash dog
or cat coming over to investigate her
confused as to where their former owner
had gone this time though there was just
a box standing outside it wasn't was n
huge in fact it was almost entirely
empty almost picking it up carefully in
case there were baby birds or a nest of
unhatched eggs inside Harper opened the
cardboard flap to reveal a rock sitting
in the Box was a single solitary Rock an
oval of smooth Granite with a paper note
next to it reaching in she retrieved and
unfolded the scrap please care for my
pet rock was written on one side in a
messy uncoordinated scrawl immediately
assuming that this whole thing was some
kid's idea of a joke Harper tipped the
rock out onto the ground and threw the
box in the trash she had more important
things to focus on within the next hour
alone people brought in a concussed
parakeet a bat infected with rabies and
a squirrel that had survived being run
over by a moped into the shelter work
had been so busy that by the time her
shift had ended Harper had barely
thought about the pet rock prank that is
until she was getting ready to leave
she headed through the side door mainly
so that she could do a final check in
case any animals had been left there and
someone had forgotten to hit the buzzer
there was nothing there and Harper
hooked her bag over her shoulder
shutting the door behind her something
the size and weight of a baseball
knocked against her foot causing her to
look down and see the rock the same one
from earlier only now it had flipped
over probably after she had tipped it
out of its box on the side facing up at
her the rock had a shiny metal zipper
fast and shut curious Harper picked it
up to take a closer look it didn't seem
like the zip had just been glued onto
the Stone's surface it was embedded in
it actually part of the rock itself and
there was something sad about it sure it
was just a rock an inanimate lump of
stone but for whatever reason a feeling
of pity crept up on Harper causing her
to slip the rock into her bag as she
headed for the parking lot it was
starting to get dark by the time she got
home heading up to her room and flipping
on her lamp Harper placed the zipped up
Stone under its light and took another
long look at it although she'd first
thought it was purely a joke now she
couldn't tell if it was some elaborate
art piece or a quirky Garden ornament
the thing was solid Stone all the way
through surely the Zipper was just for
show there couldn't possibly be anything
beneath it to her surprise the metal
Fastener began to part as Harper dragged
on the puller and slider down down from
the top stop towards the bottom one it
was relatively easy not even some of her
own clothes unzipped as smoothly as this
rock as soon as the slider connected
with the bottom stop the teeth of the
top and bottom edges parted revealing
more teeth below except these almost
looked like human teeth they opened up
to reveal a mouth a part of the rock
just like the zipper which took the
place of its lips the moment the mouth
opened let out a tiny sound like it was
breathing which startled Harper with a
Yelp she dropped the Rock from her hands
and it even made a tiny grunt as it fell
to the floor it was alive seeing it hit
her bedroom carpet Harper stared utterly
bewildered at the Rock its toothy mouth
almost looked sad like it had curved
into a frown then she heard the sound it
was making perhaps it was her years
working with animals at the shelter and
her long- held sympathy for them that
had given her a sort of protective
Instinct for all living things or maybe
it was just the bizarreness of the
situation of having a rock with a mouth
whimpering in pain on the floor in front
of her either way Harper felt compelled
to pick the lump of stone back up and
place it gently on the desk its mouth
seemed to smile a bit more as she did
while it seemed creepy at first the
compulsion to take care of this helpless
Little Rock only got stronger grabbing a
pip head and pouring a glass of water
from the faucet Harper started to
squeeze out droplets of water Into The
Rock's mouth she had no idea how it was
able to drink but that didn't seem at
all important or relevant in order for
her to care for it after all every time
a parrot or duck or Crow was brought
into the station the procedure was
similar Harper would have to pipet them
water or medicine it didn't matter how
they drank it just because they had
beaks it was the same with baby animals
puppies and kittens especially who might
need bottle feeding if they were only a
few weeks old as much as she was
starting from scratch and would normally
be completely baffled as to the best way
she could care for the Rock right now
Harper was pulling on her experience at
the shelter to nurse it back to health
if she was in fact using her instincts
and not being influenced somehow over
the next few days Harper looked after
her Newfound patient as if it had been
her lifelong pet as to why she was
taking such care of a rock or even what
she would eventually do with it Harper
didn't really have much of a clue but
the answer to those questions didn't
feel as important as looking after the
rock she'd leave for work in the morning
only to count down the hours through her
shift until she got to go home and tend
to The Smiling Stone throughout the
course of her working day she would
pocket supplies to help her take better
care of her new pet everything from
medicine in case it got sick or picked
up an infection of some kind to bandages
and other materials she could use as
beding grabbing a fresh clean plastic
container for it instead of an another
cardboard box Harper was gradually
fashioning a nest for the toothy Pebble
and for the most part it seemed to be
working some deep-seated feeling told
her that her efforts to look after the
rock was gradually making it feel better
every day and then it started talking it
wasn't exactly articulate or eloquent it
didn't even seem to know that many words
other than the two it was weakly
repeating when she came home from work
one day need eat it r grasped a horse
whisper passing through its unzipped
lips rushing over to it barely
questioning it Harper tried filling up
her pipet and giving it more water The
Rock spat it back out before speaking
again no drink only
eat what what do I need to feed you she
asked only again not questioning the
absurdity of talking to a rock maybe
after this point after getting over the
fact it had a mouth it wasn't much of a
shock that the stone also had a voice or
could her compelling need to care for it
make her oblivious to the strangeness of
this situation of course this wasn't a
situation that many people had also
found themselves in this meant that even
a quick cursory internet search for what
do pet rocks eat didn't yield many
useful results only a few joke articles
and nothing that actually gave Harper an
answer she could act on all the while
her Rock was still croaking out the same
two words repeating them on a loop its
little voice getting more and more more
forceful each time need eat need eat low
on options Harper left some bread crusts
in the Rocks Nest hoping that would be
enough to at least satiate the Rock's
obvious hunger it paused either smelling
or sensing that it had been offered
something to eat feed it rasps before
opening its mouth wide with a tiny
expectant picking up the crusts one by
one Harper broke little pieces off and
fed each bit to a rock she sighed as a
sense of overwhelming relief came
flooding over her glad that she'd found
a way to feed the mouthy little mineral
if only it had worked for longer only a
few hours later Harper was met with more
scraping demands from her pet rock the
insistent sound waking her up in the
middle of the night but this time as she
offered it more bread scraps it refused
to eat them it was still the early hours
of the morning by the time that Harper
had gotten through offering the rock
every different type of food in her
kitchen eventually giving up up through
sheer exhaustion she folded her pillow
over her ears trying to drown out the
constant cries of eat eat but it didn't
do enough to allow her to get to sleep
at any rate the feeling that she had to
care for this talking Rock was keeping
her awake as much as the noise staring
across the room purposely facing away
from her pet rock Harper's eyes fell
over her work uniform the logo of the
animal shelter stitched on it was just
about visible as the gentle glow of
Street lamps bled through the the
curtains and seeing it along with her
keys clipped onto her belt that lay on
the floor gave her an idea that might
work desperation and the need to sleep
getting the better of her Harper climbed
in the car having put a jacket and jeans
over her pajamas the streets were all
empty at this hour almost pitch dark and
deathly silent but it made driving from
her home to her workplace a lot faster
than usual all the while The Rock's
voice was getting more and more
demanding from its container that she
had strapped to the front passenger seat
sneaking up to the side door Harper
turned her key in the lock pulled it
open and slipped in doors the moment
they heard the sound of the door
shutting a number of the dogs that had
been resting securely in their cages
woke up and started barking the noise
loudly echoing around the shelter even
though it drowned Out The Rock's tiny
voice it felt as if its words were still
ringing in Harper's ears compelling her
to go through with something she really
didn't want to and yet it felt like one
of the only other options she had left
she decided it would have to be the
squirrel rationalizing the choice in her
head in an unpleasant but purely
calculated logic based way it made the
most sense earlier that week the bushy
tailed Woodland forager had been hit by
a moped it had barely survived given the
number of its tiny bones that had been
broken in the force of the impact
finding its cage it was still asleep
heavily sedated on the dosage of
painkillers the shelter's resident vet
had given it gently scooping it out of
the cage feeling its fur against her
cued hand Harper looked at her pet rock
its container on the table she
remembered that it liked to be fed
directly swallowing an urge to be sick
that was rising at the back of her
throat Harper opened a drawer in the
vet's office and pulled out a surgical
scalpel when her boss at the shelter
heard there had been a Breakin and
reviewed the footage on the building's
security cameras they were shocked at
what they saw though the angle obscured
what Harper was doing the blood left
over over and one missing squirrel
seemed to be enough to go on that
coupled with the fact that she had
broken in after hours and the numerous
supplies that had gone missing from the
storage cupboard led to Harper being
dismissed she was fired from her job at
the animal shelter forced to hand over
her keys and uniform while any other day
this would have devastated her the
events seemed to wash over Harper pretty
quickly she was more relieved no pleased
with herself that The Rock had stopped
begging her to be fed her plan had
worked for now it took about a week for
her pet rock to start demanding food
again this time just the sound of its
voice made Harper frantic any ordinary
human food she offered wasn't enough it
didn't want that she already knew
exactly what it wanted the only thing
she'd fed it that had sustained it the
big problem was that now she didn't have
her keys it would be near impossible for
her to get into the shelter again yet
still the forceful command to be fed
kept up day and night hour after hour
until Harper considered the only thing
she had left to give her pet rock
lifting it out of the warm Nest she kept
it in her fingers were gripping the
smooth Stone tightly her arm was tense
in fact both were one of her muscles
strained while she held the rock the
other in anticipation hovering it above
her opposite arm Harper could feel the
tiny breaths of her pet against her skin
almost like it was so excited to eat
again that it was panting with
expectancy she put it back down on her
desk quickly running into the bathroom
it wasn't that she had changed her mind
she couldn't all she knew was that she
had to feed her pet rock Harper just
needed to grab a cloth to put it in her
mouth clamping her Jaws down on it to
muffle her scream as she let the Rock's
teeth sink into her Flesh Blood
trickling down her arm nobody saw much
of Harper afterwards her friends from
the shelter would continuously call her
cell phone only to get no reply she
barely paid any attention to the ringing
eventually just letting her phone
batteries die and not even bothering to
charge it back up it wasn't important to
her the only thing that mattered was
caring for her pet rock in Harper's head
it needed to be kept safe and fed and it
was her job to look after it to the best
of her ability she had enough leftover
medical supplies that she lifted from
the shelter bandages antiseptic spray
rubbing alcohol tranquilizers to treat
her wounds after a while it almost
stopped hurting knowing that she was
helping keep her pet rock fed being so
emotionally attached to it made all of
the pain more bearable even when she
woke up one morning to find that her
Rock had rolled off her desk onto her
bed it hardly phased her nor did seeing
that it had gradually eaten her leg
during the night gnawing through tendons
and bone as she slept leaving her Sheets
still slick with blood when she awoke
despite having lost most of her capacity
for rational thought Harper decided it
would be best to plan ahead for when she
was gone she knew through some Twisted
form of logic that she wasn't going to
last forever there was only so much of
her she'd be able to feed her pet rock
for so long Harper held a pen in her
hand as best she could with all the
fingers she was now missing she scrolled
out a note to whoever found what was
left of her in messy uncoordinated
handwriting please care for my pet rock
if keeping an SCP as a pet is an idea
that appeals to you but you want one
that doesn't come with the added danger
of eating you alive then why not go and
check out SCP 529 Josie the half cat or
if you really aren't a cat person or a
half cat person but still want to adopt
your own anomaly then we might just have
the perfect list of candidates in top 14
friendliest scps